hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to hoonipop i imagine
that i'm going to be a lot more charming
than i once was but also there's a
little bit of an interesting thing to
discover uh there's levels i looked at
this casually and i wasn't quite
understanding exactly the implication
but then i remember the actual
implication from the first game which is
that i need to um
level up and i haven't leveled up like
at all i've been struggling at level one
because i'm just not getting very many
bonuses however these will help yield
more points and because i'm
hey oh but oh but oh by ew
but
i want to go back to
candace and abya
because what i need to do is i need to
buy those shakes that's really the
fundamental principle of it i need to
buy the shakes the shakes are what level
up those various skills that are going
to make it a little bit i can't believe
i went all day without wait no i forgot
about this morning
and this afternoon
food i'm guessing food which one of you
likes romance neither of you okay so
these smoothies aren't gonna do me
anything for you guys i should have
found someone that was romantic
which is neither of you guys what gifts
do you have you got plenty gifts okay
um
i probably we're gonna make this happen
but i can't help myself i know you can't
help yourself in a lot of things
describe the taste of
a lady
oh you asked me this before whoa it's a
bit fishy
i can understand why you would say that
oh god i'm sorry i'm sorry i you can't
understand anything and i say something
i want to ask you what's that can i have
some money pretty please well the thing
is i actually don't do you have seeds
what kind of seeds does it make you feel
good and see funny colors when you eat
them
oh i don't know i actually haven't eaten
any of them i've turned them into
hamburgers and shakes i don't know
exactly know where the store is i think
they just pop out of my tablet that i
have here that helps me find women in
the area
so there's that anyway
yeah me too also you you include you me
and you
anyway thank you
thank you
now this here's a lot fancier than the
back alleyway yeah i know we i don't
know if we've been here before but
maybe this has been discussed at some
point in time prior to this
either way get ready for the seduction
of your life
maybe okay let's start with you and the
heart
blam
love it
you're getting all the heart juice
free moves
love it
very much love it
oh no exhausted
what about this i know and then this
i am good i know all right let's get
let's get down to business
we got to get down to brass tacks
so i'm gonna i'm gonna approach this
with like it doesn't matter if i fail
like i'm not worried about failing right
now
because i'm very under-leveled so
if i just go for it maybe honestly i'd
do better than everything i've done
prior to this i would not be surprised
if just
flailing at it
somehow makes me do better
okay now spread your spread that and
then
shoot your
uh
your
hearts into the thing
you're welcome now i can't see anything
probably you don't like that yeah
whatever you'll like it i'm just gonna
freaking go for it man freaking go for
it lube up be patient
[Music]
i don't deserve it i know you don't i
know you don't okay watch this
i don't know oh i forgot you're the
heartbreak but it don't matter
i don't remember
i don't remember nothing
not before
[Applause]
it doesn't matter
what i do
i'm gonna lose anyway
so why don't i
just have some fun
[Music]
see exactly about the same as i did when
i actually tried so it just goes to show
that i need to not try on these dates
you're not worth my effort get out of my
lavish luxury hotel room
anyway i'm gonna go uh try to
establish some more relationships with
people as opposed to just constantly
going for the ones that are on the
precipice of love and pushing them over
the edge the cliff of love good morning
all right you both want orange chicks i
should have bought the orange shakes
yesterday but here we go okay you're
gonna get you okay you're welcome you
i know wow that's just the pick-me-up i
needed i know let's
frickin go
close it couldn't hurt to take a break
and do something fun no trust me this
will be very fun we're all going to look
at colors and shapes and we're going to
match them up and you're all going to
help me because if you don't help me i'm
not doing the sex with any of you
i'm a certified massage therapist too
so
who wants to go first
me
me i will go first i promise i will go
first i promise i don't know i'm
promising that but i promise
[Music]
fun but exhausting yeah i know
i have that effect this is actually
better i don't know why i was taking so
long before this is more fun just to
just to kind of like you know do the
puzzle you know play the game what is
this
give this another shot bam son where'd
you find the host of my life sorry
didn't mean until i did that looks
promising if only i could capitalize on
it i can
that's amazing it is amazing why is this
not giving me anything give me the
goddamn orange oh i swear ah
suck orange
i know pretty good i'm not going to
go ahead i don't want to slow you two
down i know yeah yeah don't you know
slow down no slow for nothing
feel free to spoil me more i can't again
no money at all actually zero dollars uh
really
money
zip
yeah hello a plan an amount of money or
moves same thing right okay so this is
fine this is fine it's fine
it's fine
whatever there's always next time right
yeah well maybe i don't know i'm a busy
guy maybe you guys disappointed me you
know you ever think about that so this
is fine it's fine everybody it's fine
every day is another opportunity to buy
smoothies and when it comes down to it
love equals smoothies you get smoothies
you get good
[Applause]
tattoos
nora
is that your girlfriend's name or
something hmm oh thanks nah that's me i
got that back when i was like 19. oh
[ __ ]
nice chess piece i've been meaning to
get something done on my chest
i was just about to say the same about
your nose stud i really gotta get one of
those no stud is that your only piercing
no stuff nah i got another one she got
giant hoops
you can't tell
uh
you [ __ ]
yep
i don't have any tattoos or piercings
but i also feel compatibility with the
both of you i think we all agree on that
red i have a red slushy okay red slushie
for you
i'm gonna buy the green slushie because
even if it goes bad then it's gonna be
fine okay why is there no other gifts
for specific people besides the toddler
toys that i'm seeing because those seem
like important things in addition to the
whole slush thing uniques i gotta i
gotta just look for uniques okay so
fashion model fashion model okay that's
good there's a fashion model right here
i think anyway i'm pretty sure either
you like sex okay good all right ravioli
that spells sex for me you stuff ravioli
in your face
and you stuff a hot dog in your face and
then you shut up and you get this this
here
i know hush and then you the uh the the
the fashion what i wish spunk tasted
like
weird
what
i didn't think these were coming out
until next year
how did you get these i've got fruit i
don't know fruit lots of fruit i collect
fruit you know all the fruit that jumps
out of your body like i get that okay
let's go on a date hey hey as long as
you're paying
i have no money because you're going to
be really disappointed
a little money
you're gonna anyway
have you heard the people pee in this
pool
so this is your plan to get us wet huh
anyway what do we have here
a whole lot of dick and plenty of diddly
uh absolute
garbage oh nope not garbagio oh i feel
you
i feel me too all the time
oh right you have that
ah sick i know okay uh that'll exhaust
you but that's fine
[Music]
be exhausted why do you guys get so
exhausted so easily with some cardio or
something i don't know i'm not trying to
get married here yeah yeah i know
i'm complaining damn now we're getting
somewhere now we're really getting
somewhere now we're getting somewhere
okay
okay nice nice and excited i've got a
setup for passion whatever whatever okay
all right whatever
whatever
let's do this
don't touch me okay i need another setup
here i don't quite have one
let's see what this does great deal i
know sweet deal
this oh i feel ya i feel i feel many
things
okay cool um
this is dope i'm complaining no one
should
i got to go back unfortunately i have to
go back so i'm sorry please don't be mad
at me but i got so many i've got so many
moves left that this cannot go wrong
this literally cannot go wrong my point
level is too big to fail
literally i am unstoppable there is no
stopping this no matter what it's like
my points only go up
that's the lesson to be learned here is
that my points only go up uh we don't
need sentiment but
[Music]
that's enough okay
big points
oh [ __ ] we're done
[Laughter]
i guess that actually was like more
skill than anything i'm not a 100 sure
but
whatever
anyway thank you for the fruit thank you
thank you you guys want to like thank
you go out again or whatever wow
i'm a busy guy i got a lot of things to
do by the way dope kicks nora those are
the new additions right
shh i wish i had that kind of [ __ ]
money nah these are knockoffs oh okay oh
yeah you want the real deal i can get
you a pair
yo shut the [ __ ] up for real don't be
playing with me like that
yeah i've done some modelling work for
them so
i know people over there
no [ __ ]
damn fine thank you i owe you one i
could get you a slushie
don't mention it okay
i strapped your [ __ ] you scratched mine
that sounds painful uh oh
i i'm detecting something mostly on my
end i have no idea what's going on in
your end okay whatever uh let's go set
up another we're on speed mode now
i'm literally slamming speed with
candace
hello wait a second uh-huh candace
little candy from down the street is
that you
uh
am not supposed to know you
it's paulie remember
i used to babysit you when you were
little oh
no
that's really you
wow
you look really really different now
look who's talking
you certainly blossomed i'm in love with
this pink aesthetic you got going on
yeah it's mostly pink what are you doing
with yourself these days
i'm a stripper
good
[Laughter]
wow theirs is so much to catch up on
this would be very weird former
babysitter dynamics but you know porn
game so whatever you know i'm not going
to question anybody want a slushy
actually i don't know if i have sm
smooves i don't actually have i've got
smoove who wants moves move eeny meeny
miny smoove
makes me real happy yeah you know me too
me too i've never drank it ever but me
too
i've got something else you're gonna
like
take one of these
i'm really good at this toy oh wow
that's great so i got everything that i
need here do you guys have date gifts um
you don't have one but i could talk to
you like i guess i could talk to you
she did not just do that i cannot
believe this yeah
yeah
talking about ashley no i never say that
about ashley i adore ashley
there's this other beauty teller uber
clarissa she's kind of my main
competitor right i just checked her
latest video and she stole not only my
idea but my format and my intro
if that's how she wants to play fine it
just so happens i might have some dirt
on her that's true maybe it's time i
make a little video letting her fans
know what she's up to behind the scenes
that's fair that's fair that's fair
whoa drama queen oh well just don't let
her be upset that's totally fine that's
not a big deal but i'm taking this
moment to say that i'm trademarking
hello the word hello is an intro in my
videos that's mine i'll sue you if you
ever say hello okay good let's go on a
date whatever you want handsome i'd do
anything for you thank you
thank you
you look you guys like the roof of these
airports why are we here again
right the date yeah the date hey welcome
to the date it's us you me
us together the three of us really
sharing experiences and moments of quiet
contemplation i often find that
i'm gonna blush the best of uh memories
are formed with the
farthest of strangers we know barely
anything about each other and yet here
we are
all right i don't know what i'm talking
about your drama queen you're
okay so don't make either of them upset
is what i'm gathering from this i need
to get rid of these hearts we gotta get
hearts real hearts in here not these
fakey hearts um but that didn't help me
put him in any kind of an order [ __ ]
what the hell is this about okay let's
go back to you get this
yeah that's more like it let's not
really like it because i still don't
have the hearts in an order where i can
make combos
all right i'll just do the garbage then
[Music]
and it ain't given nothing it's given
nothing to me
i'm gonna scream i'm gonna scream
top of my lungs i'm gonna scream oh
give me a red oh my god i'm going to
explode my brain
not even any sentiment token they're
giving me literally nothing
i'm getting literally nothing
nothing
i'm getting nothing
big oofs all around oh here we go
look at that look at that that's nice
well that would have been nice many many
moves ago and now i'm officially out of
moves and that didn't work out well but
okay that's fine i'm just here to make
friends
that's all i'm here for making friends i
think we deserve
what do you deserve
people only deserve what they get with
their own hands hello boardwalk
[Music]
i am on the way
love is waiting for me on the other side
of destiny and i will find it
i'm sookie what's your name
uh nora
is there something i can help you with
nope just saying hi so hi
hi
man i'm detecting some compatibility
here definitely
okay uh how about we hey guys uh welcome
to me being here um i'm going to give
you stuff now you take it
sweat whatever you guys want food i have
food you want
muscles i got
muscles
sometimes i can't decide if i like anime
more or food more
good conversation we just had there
hello hi uh
genre i don't know if i'm gonna see a
movie i kind of want to laugh you know
so like probably comedy i guess that's
fair that's a good we have such i'm
detecting some compatibility between all
of us yeah
oh yeah
yeah i don't think nora is showing how
excited she is but i think nora is
exceptionally excited by the way the
date's in my hotel room
with rose petals yeah the room looks
nice now but you should see it when i
have to clean it
huh what's that sorry i didn't hear
anything i went momentarily deaf i'm
just gonna speed through this i didn't
even give you a gift
you know what i don't feel too bad about
that let's go
let us go let's go
oh let's go
you ain't forgetting what i did hey i
got you a smoothie maybe i don't know if
i got you a smoothie but i got someone a
smoothie
yo
hold up there's no stopping this train
baby we keep rolling no matter what
no matter how bumpy the track gets
oh
me too you know sometimes me too
get exhausted energy right now yeah i
don't know i i have that effect on
people they just fall asleep around me
and it looks like we're
cruising into another sweet loss uh but
that's okay hey i learned a lot from
this about myself and about youtube so i
think all in all you can turn that
loss into a win
that's right i'll be on my way okay take
care ladies take care take care ladies
super duper not fun pretty fun right if
you think about it it's pretty fun
yeah
yeah anyway i gotta go i'm bouncing
between dates quickly
because that's just how good i am
no way get the [ __ ] out of here you're
40.
you don't look a day over 30.
you flatter me
i do my best to
keep up my appearance i don't know why
but seriously you could be a model
take it from me you definitely have the
look
well i can't take all the credit
my plastic surgeon is a real miracle
worker
ah
you've had a little work done
a little work done
yes i suppose you could say that i don't
know why i'm just getting ladies rescue
vibes are they the same voice actor i
don't know why but the voice is just
making me i suppose you could say that
make me feel things uh who wants lazani
who loves lasagna
open wide here comes the lazuni oh
good smooth day
nah i love you guys have a smooth day
it's faster than you yeah well here's
two you finish mine you're so fast this
is what i wish spunk tasted like sex two
i got sex too two times see i needed
double points because when i have double
points it's infinitely easier to win
we'd make a killing selling these by the
pool
what is your accent we're good to go
let's date hey you mean such a
well-mannered request from such a
well-mannered young man thank you
thank you uh also thank you
it's more compliments than i've ever
gotten in a single sentence ever well
this looks boring you better have
something good up your sleeve
yeah my dick it's up my sleeve that's
how long it is
shut up
ma'am
is your robe okay keep getting
distracted in this game don't know why
all right let's go for it
[Music]
seeing a whole lot of nothing
man we are we are in a drought
look at you everybody relax i'm back
come back look at me
what about me i would love to get this
in a five bell triangle
that's right
trying to chase those never work out so
whatever i'll just let fate decide
and then i'll scream and rage against
god once he once he turns his back on me
how dare you
leave me in my time of need when i'm
playing a porn game
i would love to get something here but i
just couldn't well i guess i could do
this screw you be upset minutes without
doing that doing what i don't know what
i'm doing you think i'm in my mind
landing any of this you think hey this
is working out in my favor no okay we
got well i like bells bells are cool
here's another bell bells are neat
i like bells who doesn't like belle i
should be used to your screw-ups by now
shouldn't i shut up no you shouldn't
always be surprised by my screw-ups
they're terrible and i'm terrible for
doing them um
remove all these all right
sometimes sometimes not now not right
now now i'm very bad too bad the only
thing i've been getting combos of is
moons and both of you hate moons that's
fine i'm not mad about it
why would i be mad about it
too bad you both hate the moons good
thing i have so many
i've never been
what did i do to you it sounded like it
went great sounded like it was awesome
what are you complaining about all right
is there any other bell move that i can
make it doesn't look like it so i think
i might be
ble-boned i might be the boned adult
it don't matter none unless oh
interesting well it's still not going to
be enough because if i do this there's
no way that's going to be enough points
it's just not going to work out i don't
give a second chance
damn like by that much by that much but
it's okay it's okay
give right out of the tits right out of
the toss-hoss i have failed so much
today i know i know i know i know i know
i know i know i know but i did it on
purpose i'm gonna say that i failed on
purpose because
i'm great and i want to feel what it's
like to be honest i see
so you have issues with your parents as
well
i'm sorry to hear that um yeah
my parents pretty much [ __ ] hate me
and wish i was never born
they won't let me do anything it's like
um hello
i'm
18. that sounds horrible
one time i took my phone away for a
[ __ ] week
i'm not even kidding
all i did was crash this stupid car into
a stupid treat
what about you
um
well i once left the house without the
proper covering on my arms and legs
i'd rather not talk about what happened
but it's in the past i'm okay now
i'm also here
listening to your very personal story
would you like
some kind of voodoo
oh my god this is basically like exactly
what i needed for my next sean you're
welcome a musician
music why don't you how about a phone
would you like a loofah
fair enough butt plug nice
that's pretty good i'm buying that
that's pretty good maybe just for me
anything's better than hanging around
here by this lovely ocean and these
lovely boats i can't wait to get on a
boat
wow i never thought i'd have the chance
to be on an actual cruise ship
damn up to 75
passion already we are rolling in it hey
but you oh you don't mind that lube
luba my collection grows larger your
collection of lube you have lube
collection let's get more of the reds
we need both of them why am i like nice
i don't know maybe you're kind of nice
maybe i just want to get to know you uh
lillian doesn't have a stamina for that
move well it's good thing you're here
this move will exhaust you well
my god
is there a changing room nearby
you literally aren't wearing clothes i
just want to point that out you are
wearing like nothing oh you maybe you
want to change into clothes which in
case you still wouldn't need a changing
room because like i said you're wearing
basically nothing
it happened again oh man oh well i don't
care
or i care very much which whichever you
prefer
okay i'm gonna do this
with a gift nice what is with the gifts
uh how about this i guess that's cool i
guess it's more than cool but i'm just
guessing so what do i know
wow
amazing it is thank you i do not detect
sarcasm at all
oh no
sorry
for what i didn't notice anything
see sometimes i do poorly sometimes i do
very well
seven moves up success hey
give me the fruit give me the fruit give
me the fruit give
um okay
yeah that was actually like
not shitty yeah
i know
i know i knew i was out on a date like
this well i'm just happy they don't yeah
me too
we should do something that our parents
really wouldn't like yeah
well as long as they never find out
okay
what do you have in mind drop out of
college anything you want to do that
they'd like
never let you do i could drive 10 over
the speed limit that's all i can think
about
what are we thinking about i'm thinking
there's attraction here uh we're all on
the same page we're all in the same
brain well we're all in the same way the
same space up here i'm gonna go weep
i have things for both of you
both of you too i have things for i jump
into the gift shop wait don't buy
[Music]
here take this
sh
yes
it's or just a guess you know masseuse
that's really sweet of you
you didn't have to get this for me i
didn't
we love the flip and the flop i love the
feeling of sand in my flip-flops yeah me
too me too and didn't it just say oh
level three style oh hell yeah oh hell
yeah we're going into this date right
now whether you like it or not ready or
not here we go that's weird
well i forget what you were saying sure
after all
it would be rude not to accept such a
polite offer i did ask very politely in
my demanding tone
i say we go to the private table where
we can see the ocean
it's so pretty here
i rarely ever get taken to places as
nice as this what are you wearing you're
fine the yellow sundress is actually
delightful i like that a lot
what are you wearing the hell is this
what is any of that and whatever okay
let's get this show on the road i'm
definitely going to win this time i can
tell because look at all the
look at it so many choices
what this hell
i'm coming up blank on everything
there's a dumpster fire of a grid this
is a dumpster fire it is the most
precisely jumbled nonsense i've ever
seen i guess it's my fault for not
having any of the the heart clearing
items but also i have no sentiment
there's like none really there's like no
nothing nothing
give me
anything anything
good job
wow this is just
dog [ __ ]
this is dog [ __ ] bad
this is so bad
no need indeed that really
kept me going
take these i guess
i know well i won't be able to use this
yep whatever you said
okay now right at the end is when it's
starting to actually do a thing
i got i literally got 300
points in the last three moves
i should probably be getting back to the
hotel now i'm not ending on this i'm not
ending on this yes
yes
yes this is what i've been waiting for
all my life jesse
the day just flies by when you're
enjoying yourself doesn't it yes i am
enjoying myself
all of me
and all of you and all of us together
in one hey you want some booze i'll try
to save some of this for later yeah you
won't you won't you won't it's nobody
yeah sure there's nobody outfit to go
with these you're the snow bunny these
are super cute uh
yeah i would listen to you all day
except i can't all right whatever we're
going for this
wait what what gifts do you have okay
bunny
this is a great setup this is a great
setup
wondering when somebody was going to
suggest something fun hey you know me
i'm captain fun that's what they call me
the uss uh
entertain
you
oh the strip club my old stomping ground
i was so innocent back then
oh my god
okay so i gotta figure out a way to get
this down there
i love this i don't even know what you
would describe this music as but i love
it okay so i gotta get a heart down here
somewhere so i gotta break that down
[Music]
i could have dropped that not so far but
it's all right
damn things are kind of there there's so
many opportunities here but everything
is also kind of
douchely
placed around each other but this is
okay i'm not gonna worry about it too
much because there's a lot of good stuff
going on here so i don't really need to
be explicit about getting everything
perfect god i want this red right here
god i just need to get rid of these
oh my god this is how i lose it because
i get oh there it goes god
damn
you
[ __ ]
that's fine oh i should no i didn't know
i haven't lost your size no i
i would shush shush
oh wow i am really messing this up
there were so many opportunities and i
have screwed up almost every single one
of them in the pursuit of randomness
that if i hadn't done would not be a
problem
oh my god
how am i doing this bad
i was doing so good
everything was set up so beautiful how
am i doing this bad i will not
[Music]
okay we might
might got a shot here might
i'd say might have a chance might big
might energy
you can be exhausted because this is
important
i gotta hit the benches for a minute
that's okay go take a nap we're done
baby we turned it around
give me your fruit and seeds
yes
i'm the best
number one lover in the world i'm
getting a little tipsy watch out lola we
might start making out again
why stop there
[Music]
okay
do i need to do anything for censored
censor it all all of it's censored this
is a family-friendly puzzle game
family-friendly puzzle hour is what
we're gonna call this
perfectly
fine friendly family puzzle out
she can't take any more of them
i don't think i've ever seen that side
of you where has she been hiding
yeah that's sort of been on my mind for
a long time
me also what are we talking about i
don't know i'm going back to the hotel
room
what a day adventure fourth brave hero
into the unknown through milky mountains
and treacherous tunnels
thank you
hello hi could it be
hotter it could
[ __ ] hate summer yeah imagine if two
giant gods just started banging over the
heavens of this entire planet i imagine
it might get a little bit warmer
uh hi abya do you have anything to say
anyway shut up both of you i'm sorry i
said that i didn't mean it i apologize
i'm here to give you both smooves
yeah this is definitely like
my new favorite okay good good good just
move for you smooth for you
move should move
i like to swish it around in my mouth
before i
swallow
okay weird way to eat a smoothie but i'm
not gonna question it um goth i guess
i'll have to live another day
as long as i get to wear these that's
great that's really good optimism is
really what it's all about
um
oh this is exactly what they used in the
video i saw last night you're the freak
you it's you it's you
i've never used one of these before
right right
my phone
it's you
okay that's gonna be good for this
definitely maybe i should trade out for
like something a bit more useful because
like the move for broken hearts is kind
of nice but this is this has never been
useful okay what about food you guys
want food corn cob of corn you want a
cob cob of corn cob corn
cob cobblestone for this kind of food
i'd definitely be gone by now cob of
corn that kind of food okay anyway let's
go on a date with three people yeah i'm
breaking all sorts of taboos lately yeah
i know i know but anyway we're not gonna
break taboos we are going to have a nice
fun time where it's respectful wouldn't
it be funny if we failed the bermuda
triangle and never came back that would
be hilarious i am interested in that but
before we get to that
some
am i crazy yours
i just for the first time in a while
i've looked at your head and
like i'm not commenting on the whole
shaved side thing but your head is very
large and this is coming from someone
that has a very large head the the face
to head reach i know with like
anime styling and all that it can get a
little incongruence
but
that's it's
anyway i'm not gonna i'm not gonna get
in the way of that um okay shmoove
number one
wow
amazing i mean that was kind of a good
move i don't know why you gotta be like
that
oh no
sorry you need to you need to calm down
we are it's literally in the afternoon
on a cruise ship we cannot be the only
ones here because if we are i cannot
afford that so you need to keep it in
your pants you don't have pants
literally
i'm begging you
please i'm just
every time i look down i'm like
[Music]
okay i see a potential here but we're
gonna need some stam stem actually go
obvious and then
hope that we don't get a good okay oh
another line up there okay it's kind of
getting risky with a lot of broken
hearts but that's okay you don't like
that one okay so we'll save this for
this boom
it happened again
sorry about that
[Music]
well well well that's pretty good
damn i'm getting this is going very well
probably because i'm so skilled uh let's
go for sentiment
that way we can get the more more of
these but also there are a lot of effect
uh sexuality tokens on the board
which is good i'm guessing oh if i could
get another match before that there's a
decent chance because i would like to
get the two less because that would
discount a lot in the future value so
maybe what i could do is if that drops
there that's gonna that's not quite
where it needs to be oh upset okay no do
that let's just go with the same path
we'll we'll do this because because we
have it now
there's lots here we're doing great 19
moves and we're already 318 that's
pretty damn good to me but we gotta get
these broken hearts taken care of or
else they're just to keep piling up
let's get this sentiment going because
now we can get the lube going which will
make everything cheaper
which means that i can get this one
going for more sexuality tokens
red tokens
i'm not going to call them sexuality
tokens because just calling it that is
kind of the more i say it the more weird
it gets and i'm here to respect and
understand not
not get all strange with it uh
good morning
damn
i love it
okay here we go sentiment okay let's get
these out of the way yes and then
passion
wait what does this do
oh let's do that first you don't know
what this means to me i am trying to
know what it means to you oh god
damn it ah but it's okay
but it's fine though
it's fine
damn it
damn it yeah oh god damn it
perfect good good good this is great
this is excellent stuff this is what
some people have referred to as
excellent stuff
[Applause]
[Music]
actually damn it i just saw the green
one that was there i was so focused on
the red but that's okay
because
because of because of this
because of this ah but you have all the
i don't care if you get tired out boo oh
damn it i can't
well that's kind of pathetic for you but
it's okay
bam
still big boomers still big bam and
boomers and then come well we're not
done yet boom
is there a changing room nearby no sorry
you have to stay right where you are
don't move
thank
you got any ideas on how we can get back
at our stupid parents
my parents are so dumb too
yeah that's why i'm dumb
genetics made me very dumb
yeah we're all done
very good
whatever whatever is happening here i
can't tell because it's all like
the noises are all replaced whatever
lixie and replace it with is
so family friendly that i can't even i
can't even explain how family friendly
it is the current state of what it is so
boy howdy do i respect
all of you
every of you you're a giant head
holy what the hell is happening
oh my god my parents would literally
kill me if they knew i had a threesome
with people that i like
just met
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah literally
yeah anyway so
oh ah oh wait no this is god this is
this is gonna be
interesting there's gonna be an
interesting dynamic here this is gonna
be an interesting pairing so it's all
about getting the right gifts because if
you have the right gifts and it can it
can open up the world so that you can do
whatever you need to do
is from cyber detective nyoshi
cosplay
what a curious ritual dressing up as
though you're a fictional character
i wonder sometimes
perhaps we ourselves are the fictional
characters
oh you really think so like like like
maybe i'm a super cute anime girl
one can never know the truth of reality
it seems all possibilities must be
considered
oh
okay
all right okay
i'm sorry but i'm not feeling a very
strong connection
please but i am i am and i'm the expert
okay
if you
promise to stop doing that
please yeah yeah yeah oh yeah cyber
assistant
reporting for duty nice that's good good
rhymes sorry i thought you were a
dum-dum before i apologize i don't know
what threw me off on that uh anyway date
gifts what do you guys like
music and star and you dislike sexuality
got it complete opposite of what we had
before
that'd be pretty good
that's pretty good to have i don't have
any moves for you unless i watch move
music and star but star who likes star
you like star is this flavor come in
milk tea
i don't like boba
[Music]
wow
growing old she'll stop at nothing to
feel young once again yeah well that
sounds familiar uh but what was her name
brooke yeah i think it was brooke it's
not lola not paulie but brooke i believe
you are correct i believe i'm correct
dude that name resonates strongly where
are you getting these names from and
where are they resonating to and from my
friends say i'm annoying but i'm not no
you don't think i'm annoying no
not at all there are definitely more
annoying people
let's see no why would anybody say that
i don't know because they're just being
mean to me yeah
no
no no no
not okay
great good grug
okay but at least you can have another
gift which will kind of offset that uh
you have the stars so that'll probably
be good for you oh but you do like the
um this this will probably be a better
combo more flirtation tokens do you like
music i don't have that but i might have
something for you
okay ah
you like
taco taco
fair
it's so
good
it's a taco um i well i mean i guess
yeah you've got no stamina left trough
trough
nice yeah we've got something to convert
broken hearts we've got more tokens for
at least someone that favors tokens and
then
is
good
enough
for
me
yes all right let's do this i'm ready
you're ready we're all ready let's
i guess i could talk
is that what i need to do get their
stamina up so that i can talk to them
you want pie
you computer lady you're not hungry
cause you don't eat do you
you can't eat can you
i'll talk to you i must admit
i was a little worried about coming to a
tropical island like this
i don't care much for water
to be honest i don't even know how to
swim i think
swimming is getting the water start
flailing your limbs around i think you
might be a robot
unfortunately for me
the difficult part would be getting in
the water i think i can't quite explain
it you robo chill against my skin it's
rather disturbing
there's little i find more displeasing
than the feeling of being splashed by
water
well i'm actually the same way but not
because i'm a robot that you know of but
i understand this the ocean is a
terrible place effects of sentiment
tokens and broken tokens are reversed oh
that's actually good
that i could use that's so good yes
this is a perfect time that's so good
that that means there's actually an
outlet for using broken hearts with you
that's amazing
i'm going to break your heart 10 ways
from sunday that's cool dreams about
this place yeah dreams okay this
location is somehow significant yeah
it's significant it's our first double
date with this combination of people
therefore it is very special to me watch
this move get exhausted because you're
gonna need it it requires some time to
cool down exactly i know
i know completely i've got the moon
yes whatever that you said was
oh this is gonna be exhausting should i
do that that's quite a move that is a
hell of a move i love that move but i'll
wait one for that
and this one will not affect that
oh it did god damn it ah
but that's okay because it still is a
good move and at the end of the day it's
a net positive so that's all i really
worry about is the fact that it's good
guess what it's my big old butt
[Music]
oh
okay more sentiment
let's get more tokens on the board and
okay here we go big move
nice nice nice nice
what did you do
i what what did you do what did you do
what did you do how did you help
i want to know immediately ah
we don't need sentiment anymore for you
so let's just go ahead and change them
perfect good good good this is going
swimmingly going delightfully well
incredibly well
okay i think it's just i think it's
cruise control from here so i'm not
particularly worried
my big old butt
nice
done hey good stuff gang good stuff good
teamwork out there good hustle good
hustle
good good hustle give me that give me
that fruit kiwis pears lubes whatever
the weird thing was the light of hope
grows brighter with every success that's
great
that's really good whatever the hell
that means that's great this cyber
detective show you've been referring to
what is it about what is it about it's
actually a hentai it's about an all-girl
detective agency set in the future
interesting
they get the bad guys to give them
information by having sex with them wow
i see
would you like to perhaps
recreate one of those episodes with me
[Music]
really
omg
will be like real life cyber detectives
yeah
exactly
who i'll cosplay i'll bring my gumby
outfit that's great
all right cool anyway
oh wait um ah i don't know if i'm
emotionally prepared for this i don't
know if i'm emotionally ready for a
brook jesse throwdown cause what if i
fail my goodness
but what if i succeed
[Music]
my goodness i don't know if i'm ready
for this that kind of commitment that is
going to take place
with this encounter here is just
i wonder what my daughter is right now
oh i don't know where is she at hey i've
got stuff for you guys uh
bam we have a little shoe fetish do we
not me i just buy them by the bulk uh
you want blackout
you want the bag out the legend
fill me all up with meals like this you
know it'll be them
i'm here to fill you up can you believe
my good for nothing husband bought me a
used convertible for our last
anniversary no honestly
boost the audacity of that man sometimes
i swear
you are raised scandalous sometimes i
wonder if that man cares about me at all
you know what i don't mean to sound
ungrateful but really we've been married
for four years four years you think he'd
be able to shop for his own wife by now
it's a shame
well that my tastes are
sophisticated exactly heck you're
talking with me you're talking with me
won't allow any plushie or souvenir
gifts unless she's exhausted or upset
because she views him as cheap
oh interesting so no plushie for you
okay so what if you like beads you want
anal you want beads up your butt
you're sophisticated i bet that's for
you there you go
and then hair brush
sure that's that's all you're gonna get
ma'am but i will ooh
i will do that instead because you like
talent okay this is good so let's get it
hey
is anyone attracted and horny here or is
it just me is it just me guys
ladies
i was wondering when somebody was gonna
suggest something fun exactly something
fun is what i'm all about you ask
anybody about what's fun this guy knows
what's fun
games
the royal suite i probably reserve this
room more than our guests do
[Music]
what was i saying i kind of lost my
train of thought anyway hello hi welcome
to the royal suite this is where we play
games where we relax where we don't
have extreme bouts of infidelity and
complain about things like used
convertibles let's just not bring that
energy in here okay bam boom love it
okay
this is going
wonderfully i really feel something
special here
truly
something amazing is brewing
between us
betwixt us
have you ever used the word betwixt
what amazing word
[Music]
wait a minute
bam love it you love to see it you love
to see it
small moves though i'm 13 away
i gotta get um i gotta get something
going
okay you have three sentiment i could
spend it on either of these
i think the power would be probably
thank you
kinda slim pickins you know kind of slim
pickings um lots of uh lots of um uh
broken hearts on the grid i have to get
this plushie going won't allow any
plushie or souvenir gifts i gotta get
the sentiment up over here but it's just
really
being i'm kind of a stickler about it
the sentiment has to happen
i'm bleeding turns god damn give me a
red there oh give me a red okay
sentiment
sentiment bam that back to wherever you
found it
i can't give them
i can't give her plenty
are you kidding me i didn't know that oh
god damn it okay well i'm probably boned
now thank you this is great
good stuff gang good stuff
god damn it
oh
i didn't know that you were going to
stop her from having it
oh man this is not good uh at least
spoil me more yeah i'll no i can't
i didn't know my chances my chances
gained my chances
oh my god i just need to get like a red
one over here but this all this
gunk you know uh you know i'm probably
making a mistake because i'm waiting for
it that's what always happens is always
i'm always waiting for it and then it
never happened so i just got to give up
on it
and then move on with my life because
it ain't happening it wouldn't have
happened it wasn't gonna happen i've got
three moves to oh okay let's at least
get the
at least get the free move
okay that's it okay we got set up here
okay that's pretty decent not terrible
that'll be a bam and then the green will
go
my my my still not enough oh damn it
okay we got another free move here that
we can use might as well
[Music]
yeah i think it's boned
well this is gonna exhaust somebody but
i only have so many i'm going to need a
moment here
yeah well damn it that ain't gonna
happen all right sorry gang sorry oh
wait wow that would have been nice oh
wait one more move oh but you're
exhausted oh
[ __ ]
that would have been great goddamn it's
your least favorite oh
man
ah
you don't even have enough stamina for
it you don't even have enough stamina
for it god that's so pathetic
oh that was close if that wasn't your
least favorite that would have worked if
i gave you the eagle beats i would have
been fine
i'll be back you two i'll be back
welcome to my life
ah
that's fine look i'm disappointed in
myself all right everyone is basically
bursting at the seams hi there's just
horniness spread across the cosmos
oh i have stuff for candace though i
have a toy i have a toy for candace and
i think shoes so that's good and hey new
day means new schmoves
yeah
i stayed up all night again that's okay
hey let's talk
what were we talking about nothing
actually uh we weren't talking about
anything oh wait
i remember now oh cool yeah that's great
[Music]
oh shoot
i forgot what we were talking about
again great that's awesome hey good talk
good talk how are you doing strange but
yeah for some reason inadequate has a
reputation as some kind of sex island
a lot of people come here just to have
wild orgies or hook up with total
strangers what
that's so weird oh no oh
i like to get to know people at least a
little bit exactly like two maybe three
conversations a lot of place working
here it's okay i'm not really like that
you know listen i'm not like other guys
i'm like a prude
i just like to take things a little
slower
yeah
i get that i get that first 15 moves of
date sexuality matches director that's
fine hey
i have a gift just for you
old-fashioned uh
did did you mean to give that to me you
said just old-fashioned right here it
says old-fashioned fine whatever hey
candace
style level four oh
nice what are you saying uh yeah sure
yeah smooves movies
moves i can't afford much moves who
wants a schmove what do you like
love it
one for you
a
that's me so let me actually assign the
gifts straight up and then we'll be
probably pretty good so let's get some
plushies in here let's see if i can is
there another plushie anything that
would get rid of the
broken hearts that's good all right
let's go cow plush
all right cow plush for you fox plus for
you that's good that's good okay at
least we have a way to get rid of them
that's not gonna upset anybody and i
have pie you want pie pie
yeah hey let's talk
i forgot what i was gonna say that's
okay i'm starting to realize that
talking was an important thing to do uh
a body
i don't know
people like to grab just about anywhere
so i guess i don't really have a
favorite
[Music]
fairy i had a feeling we might be in
sync on that question
good hey i forgot i almost meant to give
you this i used to play with this all
the time when i was a teenager
that was great that was great those are
great that was great hey let's i'm
detecting some compatibility maybe even
some horny let's uh let's go on this day
game you want handsome thank you do
anything for you that's what i say to
myself in the mirror every day when i
look at myself and i give myself nice
self safe half of my
wow cool that's awesome uh but you know
let's do the whole date thing first
that's that's the more important to me
anyway of what i'm looking for
moves
it is
just wait for even more sweetness to
come barreling down the street towards
you you get all the
hearts uh you get all the hearts
there's a lot of move tokens on the
board maybe i might be actually be able
to uh get a four and
wait
i'm detecting something i get this
here
i put this here
this is gonna seem strange but
i'm not gonna upset her i'm gonna upset
her and that's fine
i should have saved oh i should have
saved the oh that was so close
why did i upset her i could have done it
without i just realized now that i
needed that stamina token at the bottom
because i swapped out with that no one
got enough five
god have you ever had to deal with being
this incredibly stupid all the time do
any of you have to deal with that burden
candice do you know what i'm talking
about we understand each other we get
each other i'm so dumb oh it was right
there my brain
it went 90 percent of the way down the
road that it stumbled the finish line
i'm so disappointed in myself i've never
been more disappointed in myself oh god
why did i think that was the right move
oh my god
i'm so dumb i will never try to actually
use my brain again i've learned my
lesson
just don't do it it's not worth it
it will never be worth it
just don't do it
man i would do this but you need stamina
don't you god damn it
so i'm so sad
i'm so
so sad you want a cow plush
i know
let's set this up here
that's nice and then we'll do this here
and then we'll do
this here and then
you'll you'll get this right off the bat
boom
now you can duplicate your passion over
i like getting gifts you do don't you
and then
you get a little more actually before
that let's give you the stamina you need
give a little more sentiment because
you're also going to put all of your
passion towards the goal
you're welcome but hold on
because you now have a lot of passion in
those loins
let's get the free move
and then set up this for the big move
here
i know my brain is throbbing again
just immense brain happening give you
all the heart you need because you need
to get that back up because you
are going to have some star matches but
not before you have this match
which you like and then go back to you
get the hearts going again and then come
over to
[Music]
uh
sentiment
get rid of the hearts
get a free move it's incredible it is
and then we're gonna
kick it up another notch with some sweet
no yes yes no there we go
i probably
pl it's probably time enough to get the
other stuff going but little more heart
very yay in fact extremely yay then
we're gonna mute a little music a little
music going you know a free move here
and there
i think we're on cruise control right
we're on cruise control it's probably
fine to do the sexuality ones but just
in case
i didn't mean to do that do not become
upset about anything leilani look at me
do not become upset about anything if
you do i will become upset about
everything so do not do it it's not
worth the risk i'm very emotionally
unstable
extremely emotionally unstable it's
really not a lot of point generating
things happening but don't matter
because we're we're there
boom beautiful day beautiful date
beautiful
beautiful beautiful date
love this day this was a great date
everyone this was great this was a great
date are you ready for a special lesson
what
[Music]
i hope so
um
[Music]
is
that's not dancing i've seen a lot of
dancing in my life this ain't dancing
you guys can't see what it is but this
doesn't seem like dancing
wait wait what yeah
i think i get it now it's all in the
hips it's all in the hips
all in the hips all my hips gain
with another girl
we've almost got all the pairs i think
unless i'm sadly mistaken and i'm not
doing my math right but we have seven
butterfly wings i don't know who has
those do i have those
uh whatever we have seven which how many
pairs could there possibly be one two
three four five
[Music]
okay there could be a lot okay never
mind there could be absolutely a lot but
we're on the right path so
oh actually let's go ahead and get the
uh first matchup yeah i think i might
have actually wanna be uh on account of
all this cave you get to explore
what does that mean i don't i don't get
euphemisms hey
sarah stevens i sent you a text hours
ago where have you been
hi mrs bell rose sorry i forgot that i
put my phone on silent
well dear
i'm not paying you to run around the
island ignoring my texts am i no
sorry
honestly
sometimes i question why i continue to
tolerate your behavior
uh
i'm detecting compatibility for some
reason i don't know why i'm detecting
compatibility here but i'm detecting it
is anyone else
detecting this
anyone else picking up on this
just me
one of you like talent you like talent i
swear it's like i feel 10 years younger
all the sudden wow that's great weird
that that's how it is oh yeah
oh yeah classy gal would that be you
maybe
yep okay this is good this is good it's
good good good good okay you classy can
you imagine me wearing those no you are
not classy i should have known that from
the giveaway
what
[Music]
you're welcome welcome welcome
be honest with me yeah of course do you
think there's anything i can do to feel
more attracted to my husband
uh for you to feel more attracted to him
or him to feel more attracted to you it
might help if you stop cheating enough
nope
all right good talk good talk buddy
yeah what's up i kind of am
[Music]
but i have to balance
pay attention to me
because cause cause um
i'm cute and nice and cool and awesome
and and and sookie
okay great 15 chance she will steal your
focus away from her date hell yeah
before
[Music]
oh hell yeah well hell no i don't know
if that's actually good i don't know how
well this is going to go to be perfectly
honest uh so no plushies definitely no
plushies
yeah fine hey let's go on a date you me
the money
i want to see where this leads that's
usually how people make decisions and
move forward in their own lives
this is fancy
with a capital f and a capital a and a
capital the other letters
oh you're adorable
sometimes
beautiful
oh you don't have enough stamina for
that please do not ruin this for me
everybody else please let this happen
and be okay
thank goodness
boom
baby
i love it there's a lot of sentiment on
the board
[Music]
um yes
oh damn it how are you already out of
stam all right whatever you then
um
yeah good move
what the hell is wrong with you
what the hell
the hell is wrong with you
sorry brooke hey how's it going good to
talk with you oh dude you don't even
like this all right fine then
oh that didn't do as much as i thought
it was going to did i not do that right
i thought that was gonna wait a minute
perfection
i'm the greatest do not steal this
attention sorry oh you have to remember
i'm much older than you
how much older you don't know how old i
am shush
all right well god damn okay uh
kind of sucks but whatever
do you have enough now okay it'll
exhaust you damn i'm really low on
energy okay whatever go back to you i
guess i'll exhaust you god damn it
why are you all being terrible why do
you have no stamina why do i have no oh
wait white lily perfect
that almost moved things out of the
places where they needed to be but
whatever we're good do not
okay do steal attention
[Music]
okay good we're good all right you can
now resume your uh whatever the hell you
were doing
naughty nanny
okay we're both kind of low on stamina
stamina
maybe i should do this
keep them coming surprised it's me
oh my god i hate you so much oh my god
you're the worst
the worst
[Applause]
really would like to get this red but
it's fine you know they don't even like
red they don't even like red why am i
worried about red
that's silly
it's okay that's silly right
silliness
ah
thank you
[Music]
hey brooke how are you doing you good
you need anything
water
here you go oh my my my my you you i
could just go ahead and piss her off
it's not like i'm gonna get the stamina
back anyway but if i don't get the
stamina back it's not gonna work out
well for anybody i'm gonna go for it
absolutely ridiculous
i know i know but it's fine don't even
worry about it don't even worry about it
it's fine you'll get there well i can
make the red now but she doesn't even
like red but now that i have the chance
to make the red i don't know why i'm not
taking the chance to make the red but
whatever
just whatever
the problem is i've gotten so good at
the game so incredibly good at the game
that literally nothing can stop me from
succeeding therefore all joy of actually
trying has gone out of the window
[Music]
whoa
hell yeah
oh hell yeah
oh hell yeah i've got two of these bad
boys okay well that's good i'll get that
eventually listen i know you don't like
sexuality but it's kind of all i'm
dealing with right now so you might want
to
i don't know have some
you're lucky i'm in a good mood are you
hard to tell
[Music]
i suppose i could do this i don't know
what is due to the bell structure
that's a lot of bells but i've already
got a lot of points i just want to do a
big finish but it doesn't look like i'm
actually going to be able to do a big a
big finish well that's sad i'm sad fine
look at you look at me
i don't know why that worked out so well
that went incredibly better than a lot
of things that i've ever done
it's so pleasant it's so goddamn
pleasant this game not bad kid
i might just have to let you take me out
again
you're cheating on your husband fell
rose can i have my monthly allowance now
please
when i feel you've earned it sarah
ah
but but i've been good how do i earn it
huh huh
oh don't worry
i'll think of something why do you get
an allowance what the hell
what the hell
this is a very transactional
relationship but okay
all right oh wonder what lo i haven't
talked to lola in a while lola
lola sorry i don't mean to be rude but i
simply have to ask
what in the world are you wearing
i'm wearing
clothes
most find the naked human body to be for
some reason
objectionable hmm no no i mean how did
you come up with this wild style of
yours
do you find my appearance
[Music]
outfit the hair the shoes i love this
look
you have got to tell me where you get
your clothing and accessories from
fashion designer i have items for you
and also i'm picking up a little
something here
it's probably a smoothie are you a
musician wait wait are you the musician
i'm afraid i have noticed you're the
fashion designer who's the musician
yep
classy no okay all right uh tapes
yep uh-huh and uh who's a baby boy okay
all right oh not that one uh fashion
model that no anyone want no okay so i
don't want too many new things
yeah okay oh fashion designer okay all
right you're good we're good we're good
there you go all right
yeah uh-huh that was great good talk um
shoes uh nope smooves uh date gifts okay
low on money ooh
damn blow dryer make it more oh
damn blow dryer blow
what do you guys think coincidence
coincidence i've recently lost my other
one what did i give you i have no i
don't even remember i think they have
wi-fi here i need to respond to a couple
of emails
you should work on vacation kind of
attitude is that i'm the same way
actually no excuse to start being a lazy
bum right yeah actually i don't know
money i can do remotely i don't even
know why i'm falling behind even if it
means i don't have quite as much time
for recreation i apologize for
everything because i am also a
workaholic or i have a busy schedule
shorten the date due by time scrapes by
taking one move after every 10 moves oh
well that's not too terrible that's not
the worst thing i'm getting a reading
of someone nearby oh i have no idea who
though
there's a deep sadness and much regret
she wishes she could start over but
fears it's far too late oh no
oh
yes oh
i am certain of it oh
jesse no come on can you pick i just
noticed there's like a
it's like a selector here but i guess
that's just what it's gonna be so every
time you come in you can see what it's
gonna be so that's good that's good to
know okay but busy schedule isn't as bad
as it could be but you don't like right
you need to consume this
that's what it is you need that it's
actually is there another one
there is another one
there is another you would do great
with those wait but those would just
give you sentiment anyway so you don't
need multiple of those
oh [ __ ]
god damn it now i just have that okay
what about more date gifts hey that's
pretty good diamond tiara that's not bad
how about a diamond tiara for you
perfect
for lola
everything for you lots of sentiment but
i don't know
not really needing a lot of sentiment
here it's like all my talent items are
gone it's okay i'll be fine
it's all gonna work out it's gonna be
fine because we're gonna have a great
day i don't know why
but i've got a good feeling about this
one me too i've had many bad feelings
since i arrived on into puna but you
know some good feelings interspersed in
there guys welcome to the secret grotto
a hidden grotto
fascinating
it seems the perfect setting for
well i know many like
volleyball
and uh
badminton very intimate you're gonna see
the the depths of my intimidations
this is gonna work well
i knew it i knew it
uh
you hey what's up lola
[Music]
you like heart
good
dude please do feel feel it feel the
energy stamina is a little low
i guess i could double it up beautiful
well yes please all right but you need
sentiment oh i'm gonna get oh you have
cinnamon
ah thanks
you're welcome
you are you're welcome you are welcome
you are most welcome
all of you're so welcome megazilia oh
almost did the thing
ah almost did the thing okay you get a
little more sentiment not much but some
i should check my email real quick
[Music]
oh
okay what do you have
random tokens let's see what that does
that's an idea
that is an idea okay this is perfect
because then more of that and that
wow
holy crap yes uh let's just get more
talent flowing then
okay yeah i know
man the the point requirements are
getting quite high quite high
well i guess
we don't really need sentiment but it
can help clear things out
that's great
[Music]
nice nice oh if i could get one down
here that'd be
grand okay i might be able to if i do
this and then this probably can't stay
too much longer what do you mean eleven
eleven elevensies it's elevensies
no that wouldn't do anything
oh yes it would yes it would i need to
do this i need you no
well you both like this you both like it
but you have the passion multiplier oh
my goodness oh my goodness damn it damn
it damn it damn it damn it damn it damn
it damn it okay it's fine what was i
gonna do i've completely forgotten what
i was gonna do this you there
and then you finished this
exactly as i thought as well we're close
but still not quite there i know this
isn't really anything but
it's like a double move helps clear some
things out i don't need to explain
myself to you i'm in charge of the date
i'm doing my thing here it's all fine oh
exhaustion
yeah stamina is a bit of an issue at the
moment can we get some more please
actually whoa wait a minute
oh [ __ ] wait problem uh no not problem
what's this
bam and then what's up what's all this
point
easy and there was never a problem even
in the first place
what's this
damn i am well i am i have just been
crushing it but i am still actually not
a hundred percent good yet i mean that's
kind of stunning um thought i would be a
little farther along but uh apparently
uh no
um
okay
nice oh my god two oh my god do not
leave do not leave do not leave don't
you dare leave don't you dare leave
you would best not leave
don't leave i know i'm a workaholic too
but just don't leave is this gonna do it
okay
way too close
hey thanks hey thank you thank you
yes please hold your applause give me
more fruit more fruit please less flaws
more fruit all refreshed and recharged
great time to get back at it hey
me too but this is my job so we should
get together and talk more about your
fashion design ideas we should i dress
only in the way that makes me feel most
self-aligned
i recently started up a little fashion
design business you know i think we
could work together i think i could also
work my way in here whole alternative
lifestyle brand inspired by your look
what do you say
i would like to develop our relationship
further
however i have little interest in a
monetary reward
not in it for the money huh
well perhaps exposure
exposure hey i have many a social media
following i will make sure that you are
handsomely compensated in followers
it'll be lovely okay we're done here
we're done here we're done here uh
excuse me we're done here goodbye
a farewell or whatever
it was good talking to you or whatever
glad i could facilitate your business
transaction oh you're married oh lucky
you
i'm still searching for my special
someone
hun take it from someone who's been
married three times
it's not all it's cracked up to be
um what happened with your previous
marriages i found somebody with more
well
let's just say
more to offer
what's your rush you're young beautiful
and successful i trade places with you
in an instant i don't know
body swap i just love the idea of being
a cute little housewife for my future
hubby
to be so naive and idealistic again
yeah marriage is for
losers yeah
yeah
that's why we're all an innova you want
some moves you like schmovies
i have so much move you like schmove you
like schmove you you are a schmove
extraordinaire you're a schmove lady
i can tell schmovies
juvies woman in charge
i know what that means i don't know what
that means okay i guess i'll talk to you
hey what's up question for me uh i guess
i do um
holiday valentine's day is my favorite
day of the whole year because boys
actually try for a change
great great goodbyes i feel like i can
talk to you about this yes you can see
is we're both in one
do you know why i prefer to have sugar
relationships
oh
i don't know why because they're so easy
and straightforward
it's the simple transactional nature of
it that attracts me
i pay and i get what i want
you don't have to worry about getting
tied up in any of that
emotional nonsense right
right
right well that's fine that's not too
bad but also uh kind of a pessimistic
way to look at life but you know i'm not
here to judge well i'm kind of going on
inside that cute head of yours okay what
would you choose if you could only
choose one
money power or fame oh
interesting
well
money is basically rocks fame is just
numbers on social media so power i want
to be goku
i like the sound of a big powerful man
that's me
many parts of me are very big and very
powerful
like my brain
is big
[Applause]
musician are you using dammit
old-fashioned wait old-fashioned gals
no stamina you guys want some grub
i'm almost out of fruit
turned all my fruit into cinnamon
yeah you this
tells me i'll be scheduling another lipo
section
if you keep giving a gift like this well
it's a radio let's not get ahead of
ourselves here okay wow that's all the
potentials oh [ __ ] so i've almost got
all the actual match i didn't even know
that it was here oh good
okay so my levels ups are leveling up
pretty leveled up so that's not a bad
start i need to give you women in charge
oh
do you like green yeah you like green
okay gr
well no plushies no plushies no plushies
we just can't have plushies uh here
stick these up your ass um and you take
this oh the blow dryer okay maybe maybe
not that don't take that out of your ass
and give me get that we're good classy
gal oh you must have seen my video where
are you
gushing about pumps all pumps okay so we
got the smooves uh old-fashioned gal bam
love it man i had so much stuff stocked
up
big gifts perfect
perfect perfect perfect we are gonna win
this we're gonna win this no one's got
any crap gifts cause brooke doesn't like
that how could i turn down such a
well-mannered request from such a
well-mannered young man people have
always called my manners well
well-mannered
not mild
well done
i can't wait to see what you have in
store for us lovely i love that outfit
polly i love that outfit i love that
outfit that is a fantastic outfit i
cannot overstate how much i love that
yeah
wait what was your oh whoa whoa
okay so this is gonna be a sentiment
light round but that's okay you like
this i know i'm giving up this five but
i don't think i'm gonna
well
no there's no way
there is no way
there's no way
more opportunities will come later
i think the beauty
i know
i know just let me work my magic magic
is being worked
as we speak
no not you
because i want
this
or all the flirt ooh
[Music]
there's a lot of romance on the grid
right now it doesn't consume them but
the flirtation would consume quite a bit
of that that'd be a pretty good move oh
wow yes
for words you should be i don't even
know how to speak half the time
they're gonna ooh sentiment
sentiment sentiment sentiment who needs
sentiment more you
maybe exclusive
exquisite and you will do this
lovely excellent okay we're getting kind
of clogged up with hearts dark hearts i
didn't get anything to clear dark hearts
damn that might have been an error on my
part but i think i'll persevere
[Music]
look at you look at me look at me
okay power tokens more power i could
have used that before i just did the
power token but that's okay
uh increased chance and more powerful
that could be good let's go for power
i answered the question about power i
wanna be goku
i really have not been doing the passion
route
which is probably my biggest problem
here i've i've been getting some great
matches but i just i no multiplier on
this
[Music]
worth it maybe not worth it oh
god oh ye gods but it's right there and
there's no other way to get it it would
clear out some of the purple i'm going
for it
feels so insulted good i actually don't
care you know i don't feel nearly as
remorseful about that as i thought i
would
nice
perfect perfect actually oh wait not
perfect god damn it this is going to
ruin it
but she'll come back right when it's
time it'll be perfect
yeah vapers whatever whatever lady oh
paulie this would be great for you to
bet you're not here so i'll just give it
to
that's the power
that's the power multiplier
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you i am just so goddamn good now
if my husband could do that i might
actually [ __ ] him
i put a puzzle together don't you miss
your hubby out here on the island all by
yourself
hun the main reason i came out here was
to get away from my husband
besides i didn't come completely alone
i brought my
assistant with me
if he's back at home
what do you do if you get
you know
all hot and bothered no i'm fathers
wouldn't that be a predicament
i'm sure we could
figure something out figure
[Music]
these are good words
well i'm horny
how about all of you anyway i'm gonna
leave um let's see what candice and abia
are gonna do
kind of left them on a high note before
but uh except for the fact that i think
i failed that date horribly and it
crashed and burned and i was super
embarrassed about myself but
[Music]
i know you i know you
you two are such a treat oh you yeah
this is
an aphrodisiac
no it's
probably just me
yeah probably just you i've kind of
switched it around in my mouth before i
swallow cool yeah most people do
when they eat uh you guys are all loaded
up let's see what's on your minds wait
there you go you're the sweetest bestest
boy ever thanks i'm a man but
of course i will
what's the heavier ton of feathers
thunderbirds
the bricks
are way heavier than feathers you're
right you're right good job
see i see too smart i'm very smart
that's great
big moves i guess won't you
move
that's mean
how dare you in in my porn game you're
gonna consult her like that how could
you can't believe this
it's really very nice of you to come in
me uh no see me come see me oh my
sorry
i don't know why that always happens
it's like i can't ever stop thinking
about
well you know
no i don't know so you're uh
me too listen i've got a fairy speaking
of my shoulder that literally only
whispers sex and nothing but the sex in
my ear
i'm glad i'm not alone i don't think
anybody is as bad as i am though yeah
probably barely go five minutes without
having dirty thoughts
there it goes again
you don't think
you don't think i'm addicted to
sex do you um
well oh um
we'll absorb all sexuality matches and
she'll consume a random sexuality token
every time a move is made on her uh
is that so bad as far as i'm concerned
more matches the better right you guys
need food i really don't think oh
you like a pizza
the worst italian accent in the history
of the world but hey you like a pizza
okay yeah
you want a cotton candy
do you want of the cotton the candy and
then on the pizza food
you
you don't need to do that i did it
anyway so eat it all right you two are
gonna go play together i want to play
too we're all going to play
dodgeball
good luck ladies i've been bright a golf
we're playing golf
i'll hold on to your balls for you uh
wait no that came out
wrong or right anyway um yes start go
exhaustion right off the bat we love to
see it you really know how to tire a
girl out i really do
uh
yes
man i'm really
going
oh but it takes an extra move for you to
figure that out god damn it but that's
fine because i got moves to spare
your b
you'll be you are b
just small moves nice and simple moves
you'll be exhausted from that but you
know nothing else we can do about it i
very much appreciate your patience good
great what's wrong hello oh i need to
get we need some stamina on the map what
is happening here we got like nothing
going on here uh
[ __ ] is this gonna ruin me
okay stamina is hard to come by
oh no oh my god okay we've got this
no
what the hell happened
it was very nice of you to try at least
i didn't mean to
failure just have it it never happened
to me i swear and i swear it never
happened
[Music]
no
one of the purple hearts accidentally
got
matched up
[Music]
i swear you two get sexier every time i
see you i know harry
i think it's time you tell me just how
many girls have you been with well
i'm a virgin
never actually been with a woman haven't
even seen a vagina
in all of my life
wouldn't even dream of seeing it before
the old marriage stop i can't with you
you can't you and i are both the
farthest thing from a virgin
honestly my [ __ ] has seen so much
action i feel like i'm starting to go
numb down there
that seems like a
what
i don't think that's how that works
listen i don't know anatomy too well i
took a few courses but i'm pretty sure
busted vag syndrome ain't exactly a
thing
oh my god
would you mind if i asked you a question
what when you get really anxious or
nervous
how do you calm yourself down
i just look at myself in the mirror and
i go thank god i'm me in all of my glory
um
uh deep breaths wow
i wish i could think more like that yeah
breathing's real tough i get that it's a
it's a problem okay so the thing that i
learned is without the ability to remove
broken hearts it does get quite
difficult so what you need is some way
to do that okay these plushies are great
but they're very expensive holy crap but
that's that's worth it the move things
are definitely great
definitely
why what
no i can't hear you
now whatever let's go for broke
all right uh what did i just get this
one wait you don't like talent
wait wait wait you don't like talent
what the hell is wrong with you
what wrong with you you made me buy that
i thought you liked talent you don't
like talent screw you
i don't like i don't like this cream
let's do this it might be against policy
to go out with customers it's too late
we've already done it i think we can
make an excellent we literally already
have done it
it we've done it you know puzzles
we've done them
so pretty here yeah i rarely ever get
taken to places as nice as this me
neither no one actually takes me
anywhere i have to take everyone
everywhere else
it's unfortunate not broken up about it
but whatever you know it'd be nice
maybe for once
if it could happen it'd
[Music]
you felt it i know you did and your vag
ain't busted don't think down on
yourself like that you both are almost
out of stamina this is a problem
how would that exhaust oh it's two ah i
see okay interesting
well this is a bit of a conundrum the
whole stamina thing i always forget
about it i don't know why but i always
forget about it it'll be fine i'll just
make single matches for now
oh i didn't mean to it happened i need
to get these closer together how the
hell do i get them closer together how
the hell
do neither of you have enough sentiment
oh i can't do anything there's really
nothing i can do god damn i am limited
on options i'm trying to even find like
a s a single okay here we go
remove the broken hearts yes this is a
good move
[Music]
perfect okay
did that help with the stamina situation
no it did not but
that's fine god look at this beauty look
at the beauty got the beauty all right
whatever at least i can buy a move oh
but i would have loved to make ah
well no beggars can't be choosers
okay here we go finally oh but that ro
oh
look at the oh the beauty god damn it
you ruined the beauty you ruined it you
ruined all the beauty we have no choice
more opportunities will come along i'm
not worried about it
like uh
listen
three stamina yolo incredible i know i
know man i've really just been kicked in
the balls in terms of stamina i
underestimated how important it was
because i'm really
sucking now
because i cannot make these nice big
moves that are right in front of my face
without stamina
when do i get tired oh damn it oh no i
might have just screwed myself i was not
paying attention to what that actually
was
[Music]
oh my god
god if i do that there's
all these lovely setups god i just want
stamina
oh god okay whatever
this is so sad this is so goddamn sad
oh you go ahead
i don't want to slow
holy hell
i love
that oh my god
let's get some talon in here oh and
finish it
no it's not done goddamn it i thought
you actually like talent you don't like
talent sorry i forgot i'm i'm a fool
you take a nap hey everyone take a nap
it's all good we did it guys we did it
gang we did it we nailed this
we nailed
you believed in me right oh
i wish we didn't have to go oh we don't
we're trapped on an island together
literally we have nowhere to go for such
a wonderful time you're welcome is there
anything i can get either of you
oh yeah
the cutest thing you've ever seen
i mean you're off the clock relax
[Music]
i just want to ensure that our guests
are completely satisfied with their stay
satisfied
i'm sure we can think of something i'm
already thinking it's all i do
i don't even need to say out loud how
horny we all are i can see it in your
eyes and your expressions okay back to
the hotel room bye everybody i gotta go
see you around nerds today we are going
to make an incredible amount of progress
we've been queuing things up and getting
it ready
for the big finish
the climactic finale if you would
because
if you look
at the pairs we've actually
we're not even close god damn it we're
not even close if i hadn't kept okay
speed time baby have i not even found
all the pair oh my god i have not even
found all the pairs okay we're gonna
make some progress
we're gonna make some progress i'm just
gonna roll
into these everyone should have their
date items and i just need to talk to
them first um get to know me hey
that's
kind of like [ __ ] though like
i just wanna order a mojito
i'm very sorry miss but unfortunately
we're not allowed to serve alcohol to
anyone under 21.
i already told you i'm 22.
it's right here on my id
duh
uh
right
about the id you gave me
i'm afraid we can't accept it
okay
but like why not
i don't mean to accuse you of anything
but the picture doesn't look anything
like you
uh just forget it
i guess i'll just sit here and
die of thirst
because
clearly and that's what everybody wants
[Music]
well i don't know why i'm detecting
compatibility here but for some reason
my
my meter is going off hey what you do
where did i put my inhaler
uh don't tell me i left it in the hotel
room
i didn't know you had an inhaler
um asthma is there like another reason
somebody would need an inhaler i guess
you know that is a good point
i did
i'll just die
and then everybody will be happy
okay all right you have asthma okay all
right well jesse has emphysema and i
know those aren't exactly the same or
even remotely the same but
that's the thing working at the hotel
i see so many pretty girls with amazing
bodies come to the resort
i know i shouldn't feel this way but it
does make me jealous
wow i wish i was as pretty as they are
oh my goodness are you kidding me at
least you're not as ugly as me
don't say that
i think you're very handsome well
that's a shame my boobs are small
i have no butt my eyes look weird
and don't even get me started on my ugly
nose
i don't know i haven't noticed a single
nose on this island to be perfectly
honest
don't be like that okay what do you like
sexuality and romance okay
well
we'll make this work
all right let's go on this date
okay
as long as you don't think i'd be a
father why would you be a bother me too
afraid you're going to butt in ha ha
sorry
oh yeah you're a masseuse i had items
for you goddamn and i forgot maybe i can
get after the date i'm a certified
massage therapist too
so
who wants to go first me me i do after i
solve this puzzle
[Music]
oh no that's fine it's fine it's fine
uh chill the [ __ ] out much oops okay
look not my fault not my fault
my fault but not my fault
bang
i guess
i'm just gonna like lay on the ground
for a minute
yeah you do that you lay on the ground
you just lay down it would be okay take
a nap it's all good
only in the middle of a day but it don't
matter whatever is no big deal
hate my life
[ __ ] all right then man you have been
getting the short end of the stick on
this one
ah thank you everybody thank you thank
you thank you thank you so much my
performance here was incredible i know
well deserving of all these fruits wow
you're really quite good i am is this a
special talent of yours always
everything is my special talent
i maxed out all my skills whatever but
it would have been much better if i had
a mojito in my hands
good point good point good point get in
so much trouble
but
maybe i can forget about that id you
showed me maybe wait maybe really
okay that's like [ __ ] cool
you're kind of like awesome kind of like
awesome
kinda you hear that you say you're old
enough to drink well i guess i'll just
have to believe you wow yeah well you
know
that's not like
the only thing i'm old enough to do
for the first time i'm actually there
there seems to actually be attraction
here did i forget something binky was i
going to give someone a binky was i
going to give a real weirdo
well i'll leave then all right you
you have your own oh the last pair the
last pair before the gods descend from
the heaven and [ __ ] us all out of
existence millions of viewers
fascinating and what do you discuss
during your video broadcast
well it's a beauty channel i mainly do
makeup tutorials what can i say girls
love makeup girls yes love makeup found
that to be true makeup is an interest
that i share as well wow i see that
i could um
probably give you some tips if you want
oh is there
something wrong with the way i've
applied my makeup
no no you look
great it's just
eyeshadow and lipsticks it's
an interesting statement
should i have gone instead with perhaps
orange and green
um that's
an option
maybe it's best just to stick with the
white for now yeah yeah okay i get it no
i don't know the thing about makeup so i
think both of you
could do with
literally the opposite colors of the
spectrum just keep shifting 30 degrees
on the huge circle
until you get to where you need to be
anyway gifts talk perhaps you can help
me put a name to these thoughts i've
been sensing
growing ever more tired of life's
routine and monotony she seeks
new challenges
and exciting risks
no were we talking about a person i
thought that was wait growing up
who was ashley
who lola maybe no brook
who was ashley i'm not ashley's ringing
not ringing no bells i had a strong
feeling you were going to know this name
by process of elimination i was able to
get there i literally did not know what
you were talking about sorry to ask but
i have to know
who's the prettiest girl you've met on
this island
that i met on the island that's
interesting okay
all right
that i met on the island
because i've met a lot of these people
before
tight competition oh
what's a girl gotta do to win that
competition hmm
i like a good challenge uh
maybe i'm incorrigible you have to
forgive me limbo consciousness and ask
questions like that
i guess i can maybe get a teensy bit
jealous of pretty girls sometimes
how good is your limbo 105 for any time
her date receives a day gift unless
she's upset or exhausted perfect great
good stuff this is good
ah
who likes what
you like talent
interesting you are getting this flower
instead i know because i i do have the
other thing but forget that
forget you ever saw that you didn't see
anything about it
yes
perfect
shall we a date with two of my new
favorite people absolutely
absolutely yes i agree thank you
don't hold back on me now i've got a
pretty good swing for a girl
sure whatever uh
[Music]
yes no yes no yes no
yes
yes i feel your energy
great what does it feel like
[Music]
please
oh right god damn it i forgot oh
shitty tit scout
[Applause]
that's okay don't be jealous
[Music]
didn't do as much as i thought it was
going to
it's almost in the
bag
almost in the bag almost in the bag
[Music]
well all right there we go then
date done and with four moves left i'm
doing even better than i ever have
before i didn't buy any slushies today
did i i didn't give you [ __ ] did i give
you guys slush did i slush you up i
believe i may understand why you were
chosen
why i was chosen oh yeah the whole deity
thing i forgot about that your smile
it's quite beautiful
and yet
it masks a dark truth
what
i sense a lot of pain from your past
pain that's with you still today is it
not
yeah
i don't
how do you know about that
i have certain
intuitions
about people hmm
wasn't always easy growing up i got
bullied a lot people just
didn't understand me i'm very sorry you
had to deal with that
you have a good heart
and great nails
oh thanks zoe that means a lot you have
a good heart
and you know what great makeup too
well we agree to disagree on that one
because yeah it is just kind of blocks
of white
but you know it's got some charm i don't
know a thing about makeup so i wouldn't
know anything about it so
whatever all right let's go see what's
up with um oh i haven't seen uh
ashley that's ashley ashley
i was wondering when i'd be seeing that
sorry excuse for a face again okay
that's a little mean
[Music]
please musician
oh musician
i do enough for you already
a musician a fashion model
yes i modeled a pair just like these for
one of my favorite brands hell yeah
style level five where am i at in terms
of my stats i'm doing
hella good i'm doing hella good
carrying on
for my cousin's birthday wow thank you
that's right i completely forgot because
i haven't visited you guys in ages ooh
that blow dryer is blow
great blow it doesn't really work out in
terms of like a turn of phrase or
whatever anyway
[Music]
yes yes
all these are good uh gifts no let me
talk to these real life what's up
[ __ ] me
[Music]
thanks
it's these [ __ ] allergies man it's
gotta be all the flowers and [ __ ] on
this island no good i was fine at first
but now they're really acting up
right if i stay away from certain things
so no flowers no flowers or candles okay
good to know good to know flowers of
candles can't have that on a date and
i'm guessing that that carries over to
nora
oh
you want a baguette you won't snuck on
cotton candy very cheap
you would like
i ain't gonna complain about free food
you would not
you aren't going hey listen we're cool
and everything but i just gotta warn you
fair and square okay don't ever try to
do nothing to [ __ ] me over okay that
would not be a good idea
when i was locked up there was this
[ __ ] who couldn't keep her mouth shut
so you know what i did
when i got out i found out where the
[ __ ] lived i trashed her place and i
[ __ ] her boyfriend
[Music]
no it's yourself never piss off nora
you're god damn right never piss off
nora all right hey if someone [ __ ] with
me i'm gonna [ __ ] them twice as hard
back i don't take no [ __ ] from nobody
all right vindictive cool uh becomes
upset she'll throw away one date gift
each that she and her date is received
remove okay so don't piss you off got it
well no need to worry
i wasn't planning on pissing anybody off
here please give me a yeah okay i got
i'm i'm loaded to the tits with every
single possible get rid of all the
get rid of the
things let's just let's just get them in
there you know let's shove them in as
much as we can actually no the power
i like the power wait what does this do
ah who cares about that
and then the super wand
the
mega wand yeah okay
hey would you guys like to go on a bit
of a dirty
you guys like it
[Laughter]
again no money here
zero dollars i have no money
damn none of my broke ass exes ever took
me to a place like this well please
don't
please don't be mad at me i'm doing my
best
all right off to a good start
maybe we'll see oh no can't exhaust you
[Music]
right uh
all right all right all right okay all
right
all right
still not enough stamina i did run into
that bit of a problem let's just make
sure we have this on deck though
careful
my hero
you hero my hero the old gift technique
huh
very complicated technique let me tell
you
oh no
what have you done no
ah [ __ ] okay well that's all right bit
of a surprise there didn't mean for that
to happen but okay we're fine we're
still alive
i don't know why i think these dates are
life or death i don't think they are but
just in case they are
we're still alive
[Music]
you gonna stop being a [ __ ] now
are you are you
[Music]
almost there almost there almost there
almost uh this would be good bam
if only i had my blow dryer that someone
threw out in the ocean
when someone was sawing a tent per
tantrum just because i was trying to be
nice and it accidentally did something
but whatever i'm not vindictive so
let's go
here guys
hey i'm down hey i'm down too
i guess what does that mean
let's see make sure the word that was
said is replaced with something that's
completely innocuous so no one has any
idea what's actually happening here even
though it might involve some you know
activities it's still all very family
friendly because without the context
nobody knows what's going on
anyway here we go bling bling bloom blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
now i can't decide what i want more a
nose ring or a [ __ ] ring
you want my advice
the [ __ ] ring makes you feel 10 [ __ ]
times better
i don't know what the hell you're
talking about and i know nothing about
nothing for nobody okay this one
don't
and jesse i've been failing at this all
my life i've been failing and failing
and failing this
we have plenty of nighttime
entertainment options i know but hang on
a second we're at the airport for some
reason answer this question for me yeah
what's up what kind of car you drive i
have a turtle
i have a tesla
i do have a high-end it's uh it's an
american navy
sounds sexy
i wouldn't mind
taking a ride sometime well no
i was hoping this vacation would
distract me from everything going on at
home yeah don't get me wrong i'm having
a great time and everything
but i can't seem to take my mind off
well i don't want to bother you with my
problems oh my god it's
okay i can help
no no really it's fine i'm just feeling
sorry for myself
forget i said anything no it's okay
oh no god no
here will will this uh will
um uh
i'll give you if i give brooke a
smoothie would that make you feel better
amazing yeah can i buy the recipe off
you i don't know what you're talking
about oh god oh no please okay
well uh okay no plushies unfortunate i'm
taking away your plushies just don't be
sad hang on i'm gonna replace him with
uh something amethyst
is there any way to get stamina i've
been running into that issue okay this
that's a souvenir i can't have that
ah
okay stamin okay that's definitely not
souvenir level okay you'll take that and
you get uh where did you go this and
then you'll also have uh
because i i assume that brooke is going
to get pissed off a lot so the only
issue we have is we don't really have a
lot of uh consuming uh broken hearts
which does get
to be a problem how about we just in
case let's just in case get these broken
heart succinators going
because that's
i really can't deal with you know too
much in the way of broken heart uh maybe
i should actually just in case because
this always gets to be a problem
i could give them food don't you like a
baguette the weight of this woman's
heart is definitely through her mouth
great good good good let's actually
start off with some stamina
at least one of you can have stomach
real treat for the taste buds exactly as
long as you two sexy beasts are going
you can count me in all right
who this is gonna happen this is going
to happen this will happen in this room
the royal suite shush i probably reserve
this room more than our guests do shush
shush everybody shush we're all going to
be so happy when this date is over we're
going to be blasting happiness all over
the walls
we're rolled on everybody
hold
sorry i had to do it there was literally
nothing going on it was it was giving me
a whole lot of dick
and not the good kind
oh my god this is awful
are you gonna be paying yourself this
time no
no i would not
pulling a move
just like my husband
great good
god this has been so freaking impossible
[Music]
i couldn't that's a bit more than i can
handle right now god damn it god damn
you
my my my oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh my god i should have done that one
god damn
you oh my god okay okay okay okay okay
okay
[Music]
oh that did it oh never mind there was
really nothing to worry about it was
totally fine the whole time i was i did
it
yeah all right
yeah
whoa
we did the sacks of this room can be
no sense in letting it go to waste wait
what i thought we were doing i have a
feeling we'll find a way to but i
thought we did it i thought we did that
i thought well we already did it didn't
we already do it i did the puzzle i put
the pixels in the puzzle oh god no
all right i guess we're doing it now
uh here and then i'm doing the puzzle
and then the puzzle is still continuing
uh the puzzle uh we get the puzzle and
then the the oh that oh
wait wow oh my god why can't i not oh
it's not working i don't know what i'm
doing i have no idea what's happening at
all
what is this feeling i'm feeling
what is happening oh i'm scared
that's not over yet okay wow this really
takes a while why is am i stupid or
something have i really
gone down in terms of ability to make
matches at all because i'm really
struggling to see anything more than
literally three
what the hell good god jesse
i think you may have changed my mind
about older women what's it
glad i could help you'd be surprised how
often i hear that hmm
i don't know what happened i blacked out
for a second there i literally
have no idea what's going on who is
anyone here
okay whatever hey moving on i'm gonna go
see lola again
oh lola
lola's lola knows what's up and hey this
this might be my 10th angel wins it's
hard to be homesick when you're waking
up to this clear blue sky every day i
know right
pretty nice
and hey new shmooves
wait what do you guys need uh okay cool
news moves
great uh move for you don't want this
[Music]
what flavor is
this all right i can get down what are
my stats uh shush okay i've already
freshly leveled up so it's not like i'm
i'm really that much closer i guess i
could do more shoes i guess i wouldn't
charge that's technically you but
okay
definitely
okay these are dopes dope as hell i know
okay you know i'm not even gonna talk to
either of you
i know pretty much everything i need to
know except you nora
let's talk let me ask you something yeah
go ahead do you got any regrets about
[ __ ] you did in the past well you know
always
where do i start every minute of my life
alone trust that i got mixed up with
some bad [ __ ] people back then
i get you i get you you're not gonna
explain any more about that but okay you
talk when you want to talk i won't make
you talk all right let's go on a date
hey damn i already like you too much to
turn you down now all right fair enough
me too i never turn myself down when i
ask myself out on a date
when no one else will
that's just a joke it's kobe lockdown we
can't really i'm gonna cool in here you
know i should come here more often nice
okay abandonment issues okay so i won't
look away too much
but i will look away considerably
because i i have
i mean slola come on yeah nora look
you're great i like you you might be one
of my favorites now pretty up there but
lola come on come on okay
really don't competing here anyway
i see that there but oh but i want it oh
okay great work
great work thanks i just got to make
sure i ration all the attention into the
right places because some people are a
little bit you know
demanding
all right
nora now all you nora it's all about you
it's all about you
having a good day nora
[Music]
you gonna answer me okay fine
you ain't gonna do that
too late i did it but unfortunately i
can't do much right now because you will
be exhausted
whatever okay not very much
damn that was way better than what nora
could ever hope to achieve my god that
was an incredible move
what a stunning turn of events
all right where's all the goddamn
stamina where where where's the goddamn
stamina okay where's
where's god
oh my god where's the goddamn stamina oh
for real
thanks yes
what the [ __ ] lola
whatever right god damn it
it's fine smart news thank you lola
listen lola i love you but
you need to not
do that
pat
you're welcome lola you're lucky i like
you okay now we're gonna make some
moves we're going to be schmoving
no stamina for that and that's fine
of the stamina
boom okay we're back still uh one yeah
yeah that's what did you say i didn't
even say i didn't even hear whatever you
said it was incredible and i i'm i'm so
grateful for everything that you are and
in addition to that i'm not going to
turn away for a little bit
you have my full undivided attention we
have so far to go oh my god okay we can
do this it's fine okay lola's gonna seem
really weird but i'm gonna look away
i know i said that i wasn't gonna look
away but it turns out i needed to look
away because there were some other moves
that needed to be made that were more
important than the moves i could have
made with you
don't take that the wrong way it's not
i'm that i'm trying to be mean it's just
the way the world works okay just the
way the world works
you understand don't you
of course you do
all right lola i'm back i'm not gonna
look away at all this time because i
know exactly what i'm gonna do
i know exactly how i'm gonna give you my
undivided
god damn it we are so far away
oh god we're so far away okay it's fine
well that was a lot that was
considerable even for just
a three match because that nothing is
providing a lot of potency
okay not bad okay i gotta look away
don't drain it so much
i don't need that much sentiment
oh thanks you're welcome
oh my god if the stamina could just get
in the right spot i i bled so much from
just bouncing between these two
if i could just get the salmon in the
right spot but the standard will not go
to the right spot why won't you go to
the right spot
okay stamina stamina
great
not really helpful is it i'm screwed
this freaking thing i'm
it's too late now god damn it come
on ah
[Laughter]
everyone ignore this everyone this is
not there's not there's not this is not
what happened this is not what happened
shut up shut up shut up everyone shut up
it's fine
shush just don't you dead don't anyone
talk to me don't anyone talk to me don't
anyone approach me don't anyone talk to
me don't anyone talk to me don't anyone
talk to me don't anyone approach me
don't anyone interact with me i don't
want to hear anything i don't want to
hear anyone i don't want to hear
anything from anyone ever
i don't want anyone to ever talk to me
ever again in my entire life no one can
ever talk to me no one is allowed
me
yes
that's exactly what's happened here
you guessed it you win the big prize you
know what the big prize is
uh
a flower you get a flower
great this is good still let's go why
not let's date let's stay in the state
no no no no no no no no no no no
i have to redeem myself and i'm gonna
speed round this it really doesn't
matter it's like monkeys typing on a
typewriter if i just make enough matches
as fast as i can it's gonna always work
yep uh-huh yep horny happy happy horny
just go feel it feel it out you feel it
do it you feel it you know it you do it
you love it you get it you got it you do
it you love it you feel it don't think
just do there's no need to think there's
no reason to think why would i ever
think about anything i don't need to
think about anything because i forgot
everything that i need to think about
right in front of me right now and when
i think about the things that i need to
think about when i'm doing the things
that i need to think about i just do it
and i don't even think about it because
if i don't think about it i don't need
to do it and if i don't do it i don't
need to think about it
and therefore if i never think about it
then i never actually need to do it in
the first place it's almost too easy
this is going to exhaust you but that's
okay
sorry it's okay i thought i could handle
that it's okay i get it all the time
happens to me at every occasion
[Music]
bam
boom
done
couldn't
be
simpler waited for me
thank you yeah of course watch this boom
that's what i thought
pow
i should have used that god damn it but
i use this spoil me more you won't ever
be spoiled enough
boom
spoilage
here comes the
spoiler
i love it i'm back here we go
are you ready
for don't even think about it i'm not
thinking about it why would i think
about it i'm not thinking there's no
thinking required thinking is for losers
i ain't a loser i'm a winner and i
always win when i don't think and i'm
not going to think because boom i'm not
even thinking about it i'm not even
thinking about doing it because if i
thought about doing that i would
actually think about it and that would
ruin my entire plan i'm not thinking why
would i think i'm never going to think
lube up
my collection grows larger exactly you
know what else grows larger my brain
from not using it boom
didn't think about it
why wouldn't i think about it because
thinking is wrong thinking is against
the law
if you could stop gushing your sentiment
all of it
we might
[Music]
yes you are
yes you are take this you know what this
means i i don't know because i'm not
thinking about anything why would i
think i'm not thinking trick question
there's no thinking happening why would
anybody think when they've got this
there's no hotness cause there's no
foughtness in my brain
i won with seven moves ahead i didn't
even remotely think that entire time the
truth of the life is this
you'd never think your brain go bonk and
no have anything and no nothing you me
here in life
oh my okay calm down happy don't start
hyperventilating again
what's happening i missed out on
everything because i wasn't thinking
here's perfect process of thought not
happiness there's no thoughts happening
because no thoughts need to happen ever
for anything for whatever reason there's
never any thinking that's actually going
on thinking is a lie
against them
pizza supersonics
here we go there's another one trip
round wibbly bop give a zap
well that's a big blurry nothing so uh i
don't know why they keep feeding me
these big blurry nothings here believe i
just did that with
misty cats mr katya i'm never washing my
mouth again
[Music]
you were great sweetheart you're a
natural
are you the same voice actors
did i just because at the end of abia
you know the same actually
was that the same i might pick the same
okay so that was the tenth
fairy wing that was the tenth one
am i done i believe you get to smack all
these titties around and i just have to
watch
what a chip you've been watching have
you been watching this whole time oh
wait what wha oh fairy wing planned
no we're not ready yet okay get back out
there and get me some more wings how
many do you need okay we'll find out
okay next time on who
i just want to eat you all up
this is definitely sequential to the
last time that i played this and i was
definitely recording up until this
moment and this definitely isn't just me
coming back to it out of nowhere and
then
look at all these weird sounds happening
now
thank you
you're welcome
i appreciate you
hey take one for the road
hey all right look both ways
uh all right have a lovely day
all right toodaloo
tiddly dee
tiddly toto
tt
what what what what what what
what what what
what what
you trying to blow smoke in her vag i
have no idea anyway
miss jessie
you're
really good at that
well sweetie i am a professional all
right that's great hey we're all
professionals here this is a
professional exchange of professional
information also hi
it's
not
five months after the fact that i
started this definitely not that um
perfectly ordinary for me to come into
this
as such as that as thus
who are you talking to you talking to me
do you
do you hear that
ringing sound
only when i match joy tokens are in a
date
so you hear it on the dates as well oh i
do interesting i sure do it seems ever
since our most recent date
i can't get this ringing sound out of my
head
oh you actually do have tinnitus
tinnitus tinnitus
constant ringing zoe's usual friend any
joy tokens from volleyball you folks oh
well that sucks all right cool um so
like i have a question
yeah would you rather be a vampire a
ghost or
a werewolf
ghost would suck because number one
you're dead right i mean vampire like
undead werewolf you're kind of dead i
mean all of them kind of have they suck
right but
at least with a werewolf it's like the
least amounted management i'm gonna go
with werewolf that's cool
hey whatever [ __ ] you you vampire go
away what is your problem teen angst
joey matches directly and we'll subtract
moves
okay so joy don't work on this date i
just discovered this i i was thunkling
about it and turns out
turns out joy don't work i'm all right
looks like we're ready to rock
musician
yeah surely damn it
damn it
all right whatever i don't feel like
buying anything i'm gonna buy something
goth girl
nice yeah
i'm gonna have to what god goss girl
didn't i just do that like understand my
style
that's like
i know
i know i know i know i know i know trust
me i know but i'm on a bit of a time
crunch at this moment and i'm gonna just
plow through all of you as fast as i can
because there are two gods that are
coming down from another dimension that
i need to
do you think you'd like die if you jump
them up here
maybe what's your colors again okay
you're blue but you know joy tokens drop
when i'm looking at you so i'm gonna be
looking at you
your thing is sexuality but at first
it seems like
uh i'm not gonna talk what am i what am
i even gonna talk about i don't know
what i'm doing why oh my god are you out
of stamina already what are you pathetic
are you pathetic is that what we're
talking about here are you pathetic
okay musashi
i saw that coming i didn't see anything
coming actually i must have missed
something
okay well i might fail this day because
i'm out of stamina
and if i'm out of stamina that's not
gonna bode well for me
man this is kind of rough
here my emotions have stabilized great
good to hear thanks for uh that
how about i hit you with the old one two
wa-bam feel your energy i feel your
energy okay let's go for
it i like it
so
cheshire lady
wow amazing it was pretty good it
actually was pretty good but whatever
you know
i know there's a good match there i just
need to buy some
time
i guess that's cool it is cool shut up
need to be careful need to be very
careful about this
i know
i'm aware i'm the one doing it well
that's interesting
[Music]
is this going to have any unintended
effects
nope
okay great oh yes it did god dammit
there was another four blast
oh but i got another one of these
all right
just just doing this just because
[Music]
i guess that's cool it is cool shut up
or keep talking i don't know oh the
stamina the stamina oh why is there no
stamina happening
you don't have any stamina stuff either
and there's this big beautiful
thing there
oh close it's close on moves
okay
let's do this
just put me in the morning yes yes yes
what that was a move oh god it had the
opposite effect i forgot god damn it oh
shoot
god
damn it
oh am i gonna be this oh
my
god oh please be enough please
i forgot
the opposite effect
your life why is my life like this
there's no one here to with which
impress my sexual ability
god damn it you'd be surprised how many
porn channels they have here
honestly
see ya
[Music]
good to see you hi good to see you hey
how's it going
[Music]
okay i don't care
shut up and also wait a minute okay hot
dog and fried chicken or you get a hot
dog
you eat fried chicken
okay all right sure you don't need to
think about it too much it's just a date
we've been on them before and it's
totally cool and this time i'm not gonna
screw it up
okay you
steal attention star okay got it
i shouldn't have gotten so angry i
apologize
yeah you shouldn't
you really shouldn't but it don't matter
because we almost got this unlike last
time where i did not got this
but now i got this
so stand back and watch as i got this
oh i got this all right
screw it screw it
okay shut up i hate you i hate you i
hate you uh no i don't hate you i don't
hate you
i hate you i hate
all right back to you again nope it's
not okay and uh let's go ahead and
exhaust you
oh we win
anything
are you sure about that
are you sure how pooped is you
how pooped is you you tell me how pooped
you is
i'm not sure if i need to be pooped or
not
[Music]
hey
can you show me your sushi oh i should
have let that
now actually i'm kind of glad that i
skipped that line that would have been
scarring to hear
um oh my
you're not talking about food this time
where are you
[Music]
what the hell are you talking about i'm
i'm actually in i'm in the dark here i
have no idea i really don't know i don't
understand anything that's going on
i'm just an ignorant little baboo
well that could have been a better match
but you know my eyes ain't what they
used to be when it comes to this game
because maybe it's been a little bit
longer than i'm suggesting that it's
been since the last time that i played
this game you know it's not really
something i play in my spare time a
whole lot of you know it's like i wish i
could say that i just constantly play it
every every once in a while but i really
don't
really in all honesty i don't i don't
play it nearly much at all anything you
know to be perfectly honest if i'm being
frank with you here
is that some kind of gang sign
[Music]
look at these blurred pixels go
oh i can't believe i had sex with a real
japanese girl i'm like a hentai
character
[Laughter]
[Music]
just found out my deal with divine
cosmetics is official
oh finally
we've been in negotiations for months
wow
that's amazing congratulations okay i'm
gonna
very own palette oh it's gonna be great
that's nice that's great
oh brand loyalists won't allow any
jewelry or cosmic dickus unless she's
exhausted upset because she doesn't like
off-brand products
how do you know that that's how do how
do you know that it's bad how do you how
do you know all right well that's out
then i guess whatever
uh
yeah smoothie smoothie
and what did you like you both wanted
that smoothie you get a smoothie and you
get a smoothie
selfie caption you have to try these big
moves on candace won't use extra stamina
but will cost her an extra move for her
to figure out all right so
no big moves on her cause she can't
figure it out but i can figure this out
because i'm a goddamn genius
for good luck
[Music]
censor it thank you ridiculous
oh my
i know i don't know if that was worth it
at all it probably wasn't
ah
boy here we go
and i'm just sucking this round the
garbage round
this is terrible this is so bad i'm not
getting any sentiment i'm not getting
any anything
i'm getting nothing
that was barely worth it oh
[Music]
can i get something
something in here
oh my god i don't know what just
happened
ugh and the worst one for him is the
only one that i have at the moment
uh that cost me moves wow this sucks
okay mister let's try this again
yeah let's
whoa i don't know what that was all
about but it didn't do anything for me
so whatever oh wait yes it did you're
scoring major points here i know
i know but at the same time it's kind of
a [ __ ] and a half
i think i'm just i'm saying i think i've
lost this one there's literally no way
that i could ever recover from this
this is just trash like from start to
finish this has just been trash
it's like what what could i possibly do
there's just nothing here that it is
giving me literally nothing
god it's like whenev when i finally do
have stuff oh man if i had one more move
that actually might have been enough
that one move might have been god that
one move away
that might have been enough the two
powerful things and a three lots of man
with performance issues
shut up
shut up shut up i'm gonna go back to my
bae
i'm gonna go back to the real
the real one
lola never would shame me the stars the
stars i love the start don't even bother
finishing because we are already
they shine so beautifully yes they shine
so beautifully all right let's go let's
go let's go let's go let's go let's go
oh the secret grotto
guys what sucks is like every time i
lose it gets harder
and so it's it's like my own fault
because i keep just like sucking
but it's also not my fault because it's
not my fault it was this sentiment and
broken heart tokens are reversed so you
want wow
wait wait wait wait
god damn it god damn it i thought i was
[Music]
how is that helpful right
god
[Applause]
oh
shut up
okay this and this and this
the day
you take that
shut up you take that
you take is this laced with something no
we're going on a date you and i and us
and we and we in three and we in us
sorry i'm a little okay i got like
vindictive
no [ __ ] idea what i'm doing yeah me
neither apparently becomes upset okay
all right cool so don't get her upset
roger that we're in it to win it it's
all good
okay we're off to a great start
surprise
it's me
hi
good to see you sookie
hey look at me
hi
okay okay here we go here we go here we
go yes i appreciate it you should
appreciate it if you don't appreciate it
i'd be very
upset pay attention to me too
shut your trap
god damn it i'm running into a situation
where i'm gonna run out of moves here
no i'm not
i
hey okay
god damn it damn it no no not like this
no
no yes yes yes
[Music]
oh that would have been great oh god oh
i'm an idiot oh
my god
oh why am i so bad why am i so bad how
can i be so bad in this game that i've
played for so long
how can i be so bad
i'm so consistently bad at this game i'm
so
consistently bad
webcam uh
no i all the time i lost all my money
that way yep that's how i do uh don't be
shy now uh what's your favorite kind of
weather clouds you like clouds i like
clouds you like clouds no
i bet you'd like a cloud i bet you like
clouds clouds or clouds or what you like
clouds do you like clouds i like that's
okay you know why because i've got food
and if you like food i've got food and
you know you want food and everyone
wants food you bet [ __ ] corn for you
baguette for you little bite couldn't
bag it for you eat that i might get fat
and people won't like me no more
into goddamn baguette or not fine
we're going and this time i'm gonna win
it because i'm the best
sensor
i think i got a case of the vapors
[Music]
oh come on
what the hell
what in the hell is wrong with you and
me and me
i am so goddamn bad at this god damn
game cops
oh sh
i will never tell you to shut up all
right i'm talking to you yeah yeah
what's your favorite uh thing to drink
yeah
coffee we love coffee we love the coffee
vicious woman i don't know i didn't even
read it part of your own body you like
that
what about uh i don't what they're doing
they're doing yay yeah at bare minimum i
should just get those free moves
i
guess this is a secret grotto kind of
crazy what was that about
a row of tokens will shatter every time
a move is made on zoe that's kind of
cool though
that's kind of cool though
so i'm not really complaining about that
right exhaustion
beautiful i know it's very beautiful
i know right pretty cool
okay let's just make sure we always use
our power points then
that's gonna
yeah that's fine that's fine we love
that
just don't break the top row now
whatever doesn't matter anymore i've
burned through like 16 moves and i've
made no progress
[Music]
all right whatever you do
don't break that one
[Music]
that's a lot of power tokens on the
board okay
i will do a thing now
hold on excellent that's great
[Music]
perfect don't move
don't freaking move i've got three here
don't move yes yes yes yes with one move
left i'm the best
i'm the best
oh
i'm the best i am the best pure and
simple i'm the best are you ready for
our first
business meeting
[Music]
business together let's commits business
make money for glorious capitalism
business
uh i propose a restructuring of our
cohabitatable
dynamicisms
[Applause]
i think that we should reinterpret the
methodologies of our
[Music]
productivity axis
i think that we need to have vertical
integration of all of our structural uh
supply lines
i believe
[Applause]
[Music]
well weird this uh brick wall appeared
strange
hmm very strange that isn't how i
pictured a business meeting
perhaps i'm an entrepreneur after all
i never really understood that rule of
not mixing business and pleasure
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right let's go
all right we got this we got this we got
this we got this we got this we got this
i got this i got this i got this i got
this i got this i got this i got this i
have this i have this in the bag in the
bag in the back of my bag in my bag my
bag is in the bag i have a bag in my bag
i have a bag in my bag
anytime my focus is turned away from
nora
five percent of the current earned
that's so much
i'm gonna turn my attention away for now
because i can't afford that at all i
can't afford any of that
how are you tired already
anyway
hi
my attention is on you 100
i'm so attentive of your needs and wants
all right i know that's all right
all right
okay
damn
well okay i know i'm the best
do not drain anything from anything
please
[Music]
god i wish i had some better potential
matches
it's early on let's just go for it
there's nothing in the pot anyway
i'm too pooped to do anything
yeah you're pooped all right
i appreciate it
oh that had to have opened up yes
you gi joe
this is absurd there should be so many
more oh my god they're all perfectly
distributed in really terrible ways
terrible ways
all right that's better i'm complaining
uh yeah you better not be i guess what i
gotta do is i gotta piss her off right
that's that's gotta be the crux of it
right that's gotta be it
it says anytime but i don't know if that
also includes being pissed off it does
not
hold up
okay it does not okay that's good that's
good to know
save that for when
she comes back
[Music]
nice get this thank you
you're welcome
are we still doing this thing or what
you know we are
100 percent
[Music]
oh you want a prize
okay i got a prize for you
i got a prize too i got it for christmas
you want to see it
[Music]
all right guys i'd like to think that i
see bigger matches and then my brain
actively filters it out because why
would my brain try to actually help me
in these situations you know it's etsy
right there like it was very clear what
was there and not yet my brain
just didn't want to see it didn't want
anything to do with it actually
actually the opposite of seeing is what
my brain did
so uh you know how it is
oh well you know
all's fun and loving war but you know
the roller coaster has to stop
eventually guys
the train is approaching the station is
what i'm saying
there we go
that's what i call the big
finish right anyway
you're real
for real though i kind of hope you do
too
i kind of hope something else or
something i don't remember whoa man
there's still more how many pair uh four
pairs left
oh i don't know if i got the endurance i
don't know if i got the endurance
i don't have the endurance
i just ate soup
had so much soup
i was going for bowl after bowl
soup
there's no full like soup full but i now
have the willpower to continue
the endurance did i say the endurance
also i have mints in my mouth so ignore
them ignore everything that's happening
in this moment you have come in this is
like hour
five of this video and if you're here
holy crap
you really want to see me [ __ ] these two
interdimensional gods
anyway
you too
also apparently the hitachi wand is op
as [ __ ] hi i'm so
[ __ ]
bored
i'm so [ __ ] i don't care hey i did it
level five wow i'm great
okay good now that we have oh the shoes
[Music]
the shoes
and the passion
oh yeah
i forgot all right let's go for it
exactly what i needed i'm ready to win
i'm ready to win i'm ready to win i'm
gonna kill it i don't have the
but i got
these
to click the mouse to make the matches
okay anyway here we go
you love it yeah okay
[Music]
no bells no bells okay and no ah i
almost screwed it up already
ah
i see
a match
made in heaven
a glorious match
[Music]
that's me
remarkable
[Music]
whatever
and that's all i have to say about that
dude
[Music]
oh
[ __ ]
i am so screwed
my dude
screwed
[Music]
oh
thank you thank you thank you my dude
thank you how rude
are you still doing this
yes
no not boring lovely lovely lovely time
for lovely people
i know
okay here we oh yeah
we're getting there
oh yeah
you guys seeing what i'm seeing
are you guys seeing what i'm freaking
seeing bam
i thought that was gonna i thought i
thought that was
well
this is awkward okay let's do some math
here right
there's a sexuality token
i could move this get that match
bam
get four
suddenly have enough for this
which would be one two three four five
six seven eight nine percent
ten percent of this would be f
four
hundred and forty seven i only need two
hundred 280 like 78 or something like
that
to get the goal i think that's the move
unless that's the thing that happens and
then i can't do that at all because
that'd just be too easy
this is the move
this is the move trust me trust me on
this one
this is the move
bam
that's the move
i told you you had no faith in supermark
but sued mark was right
that was right
thank you
thank you i wish to engage in sexual
intercourse with you both
all right
why do you say it like that though just
like ask if you're down to [ __ ]
i think that's what she did ask so um
man that soup really made my eyes open
up for the ability never mind i'm
terrible i can't see anything i'm blind
i'm blind i'm not blind i'm a genius
[Applause]
either
okay
soften my eyes i just gotta relax my
vision
and i'll be able to see everything
with perfect absolute clarity
whatever the noise was that you guys
didn't hear because it was censored
i'm not impressed okay you're not gonna
like
say anything really weird again are you
oh yeah if you wish i'll reserve my
initial comment and say instead
thank you
for the sex
[Music]
yeah
all right i gotta go i gotta go back to
my hotel room because i only have three
pairs left
then i'm gonna
nail it don't forget to check these
i've not been getting good about the
unique gifts that's probably where i've
been really lacking i'm blessed
it's you again
this is gonna be the one this is gonna
be the one there's gonna be one there's
gonna be one yes
i don't know
this resolution res this location
resolution
resonates with me quite strongly okay
that's great i don't really care you
have tinnitus starting off with a bang
not yet and starting off with a bang oh
yeah well do i really want to exhaust
that would risk losing right away
which is definitely not what i want to
do
and there are no bells there are zero
bells here
wham
that's great well
that worked out in my favor actually
thank you for that you're very annoying
good good good
surprise
god damn it yeah it's you okay great
that's fantastic thank you
for that
boom
hell yeah
that is what i have been talking about
all my life
we're right there aren't we we're right
there
i am now prepared to resume our date
good the date has now moved on to the
looking stage oh no detective zoe this
bad man won't tell us where the bomb is
well
then
i suppose we have no choice but to
interrogate him
what bomb what bomb what are you talking
about do i have a bomb on me is there a
bomb in me there's a bomb in my pants
get it out get it out diffuse it
if you just tug on wires until it goes
out
don't let it explode
other euphemisms about how there's a
bomb in my pants that's primed to
explode what shush
s'mores just a little more good shooting
i don't know i'm trying to respond to
you you have no idea what i'm saying
mission accomplished detective zoe
yes
i believe we've done exactly what needed
to be done
[Music]
exactly what needed to be done i guess i
could go to other pairs and still give
them things to up my skewer what do you
want from me right i guess i could find
them so that i could give right
that would make a lot of sense to do
that
i have not been doing that at all so how
could i upgrade anything if i didn't
interesting all right let's go we're so
good
you want to see where this leads
i have no idea where it leads
i don't really know i don't really know
will you look at this table i and that
it's just too much well it's very
expensive i am
i have so little money left i am
i'm broke
was it was your sentiment yeah no
sentiment
hmm well that was nice
not what i used to be i meant to not do
that but i did it anyway
we love this oh [ __ ]
that's fine
like hi
music is romantic
delightful
beautiful
i shouldn't have i did it anyway
and i did it all for you
and i do it again in a heartbeat
my the stars are lovely tonight
not as lovely as your eyes
not as lovely as your thighs
but don't mind me
i'm just
a bit of a slap oh my a romantic shot
[Music]
oh the way the moon shines from your
bountiful bosom
oh
no
[Music]
all right let's be again i'm back for
round
classy gal
all right style leveling shift heavy
dream that's you all right never mind i
thought it might have been but i was
clearly mistaken
all right let's do it
all right let's go now i'm not gonna
mess it up this time i'm not
it was too beautiful things were too
lovely to mess up and i won't do it
again will you look at this tape i know
look at this
table look at the freaking table
oh
[Laughter]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
come on give it to me you know you want
to give it to me you know you want to
give it to me
now
oh
[Music]
boom
slam dunk
[Music]
oh
god damn it that was not the right move
[Music]
[Applause]
oops i've got myself all hot and
bothered now and with no husband around
what will i do oh yeah i forgot you have
a husband
perhaps someone else can
fill in for him
[Music]
this is morally reprehensible
which is just my type of reprehensible
the moral kind
damn these hands
damn these incredibly sexual hands
they were just made for this
crafted
am i who am i to deny my destiny
all right sure whatever whatever
whatever what well now i haven't had my
pipes cleaned like that in quite a while
classy lady what can i say i do love to
clean
all right hey me too guys me too i love
cleaning
okay
this is it the final pair
the last of the mutombos the mumbly
jumbos
the mambly bambly's the mega palumbos
jewelry or makeup get out all right
there's no druid all right we're good
let's do this
i'm going to win
sensor
all right this is it i failed many times
on this but i shan't again i shan't i
shan't
i shan't
i [ __ ]
wow
pretty good
oh my god
oh my oh
wait okay so
i thought it was gonna be more than that
it was not it was not more than that it
was less than i thought it would be i
forgot that that's not too terrifying
shouldn't have gotten too excited about
that
a lot of moves for a whole lot of
nothing so i'm not exactly
doing great
you're scoring major points here damn up
to 26 moves i am just crushing it in the
move department
not really in many other departments but
in the move department i am
devastating all right listen to this
then we can do this
[Music]
oh
no
god it always happens it always happens
always the most inconvenient [ __ ] oh
oh
oh no oh it's fine
[Music]
close one pal
oh good thing i had that timed right oh
my god
oh that was a big one we needed that
nice nice we got it we got it ladies and
gentlemen we got it
savor this moment not that movie that's
bad move
savor the moment
save a red saver this will do it
yes
do you still think about that big old
kiss on the lips candy
[Music]
i'm thinking about it right now
huh
or kiss on the lips no one tell anything
about kissing on lips that's against the
rulers you better watch yourself i'll
kiss you right on the mouth
don't even try me i'll do it there's no
match there's absolutely no am i blind
there are no matches
oh my god
[Music]
well that is hardly appropriate censor
that [ __ ]
so
was it anything like that and continue
to censor that [ __ ]
you kissed the wrong lips silly
but that's okay
i still liked it
[Music]
atrocious
hey i did it are you proud of me
you proud of me
don't forget to chat these broads up a
little you'd be surprised when you
hey wait yeah we actually do we finally
have enough fairy wings wow
you actually managed to collect them
with a little bit of time to spare too
oh yeah i've been i've been super speedy
about this you to get their nasty space
period for days yay
look before we go and offer these wings
as a sacrifice to mount nymphojaro
you gotta be absolutely sure that you're
ready for the double date that lies
ahead the nymphogen aren't like any girl
you've ever dated before they're beings
of pure lust uh-huh i'm serious
listen all jokes aside the [ __ ] is
absolutely [ __ ]
unreal
are you sure you're ready to awaken the
nymphogen
i'm ready i'm ready oh let's do it all
right
i'm ready to the summit of mountain info
jaro
let's do it throw em in baby
i'm ready when this [ __ ] blows it'll
awaken the nymphogen and summon them
here high above mount nympho jarrah okay
cool
no whoops all i know is they're gonna be
super horny and they're gonna be in a
really bad mood great ready yeah here we
go i'm ready
oh i'm in outer space
why
oh
wow
oh wow oh wow oh
wow hi
hello
youtube
my name is markiplier
i was already introducing myself
it would appear to be a mortal moxie yes
human man in fact yes that's me human
yep business does a human have
disturbing us on the eve of our
awakening well it's no longer the eve
it's the now of your awakening in an
attempt to
date us uh-huh you got it
you honestly believe that you
have what it takes to date us yes no
immortal is worthy of [ __ ] this good
you couldn't even conceive of the
pleasure
go on go
on near these hoes their [ __ ] wall is
too strong uh-huh
your insolence will not go unpunished
love fairy now be gone with you
sorry man you're on your own from here
listen i know i give you a lot of [ __ ]
but the truth is
i believe in you i know you can do this
i've seen what you can do with my own
two thighs
oh the [ __ ] you've crushed to get here
do it for them i'm gonna do it for them
do it for the person you have any idea
who you're attempting to move uh you've
never faced lust like this before okay
well that seems like it will be
dismissing this impotent fool
and plunge this world into darkness
aha dude let's show this pathetic human
male what true rejection feels like
yes
you want us uh-huh
sure
well
let's see how you like this
why
mind control
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh i get it
oh i see i see oh i get it
i have to do all of it over again
oh
great that's great all right well you
know
a hundred moves god damn uh hundy moves
that's not bad oh i'll make it a hundy
and one baby make it a hundy in one
maybe i should have stacked up a bit
more uh
literally anything
is that all you've got no
[Music]
no ma'am
it's not
i have much more
impossibles my middle name
just you wait till you get a load of
this
oh [ __ ]
that's fine i didn't have any presents
out
and the music is
less romantic than i
was hoping for
will i
or will you regret it in the morning
when you commit to the walk of shame the
celestial flying of shame
was the
for a man
okay that sounds strange
[Music]
man i'm just chewing up moves i should i
should be doing way better than this
i'm doing so badly
so poorly
my god
this is embarrassing
wipe that grin off your face
oh i did it oh that only took 30 moves
[Music]
don't worry oh i got this
i'm only gonna get better from here
ah good okay i didn't want those anyway
oh boy
my [ __ ] is so dry
okay
oh am i
crazy or is this just not going my way
this is absurd this is
what the [ __ ] is happening i'm getting
nothing i'm getting so much
nothing
i'm getting absolutely
just dick
you'll have only your own hand
[Applause]
okay that took so much more than it
should have getting on my neck terrible
i probably have to go through a lot of
pairs but definitely not every pair
there's no way
what
god damn it oh well i can't help that if
that happens
oh boy okay bye everybody
oh
[Music]
wow
okay
i'm about as good as i can get
i know i haven't divvied up all the
presents for the date presents right but
honestly i should just be able to match
well
and
boom i'm good
so everyone just pretend like this is
the first time i'm doing this
we're all good
we're all so good
all right
[Music]
don't make me laugh
uh
two more rounds i see it in the top
there two of four okay
okay i got 41 moves to get two more
that's not good for my normal ratios but
whatever
i can do it
my [ __ ] is so dry
okay 13 moves to get this i got it yeah
this is it i'm gonna win this
definitely
100 percent
well if i hadn't goofed it so hard i
would have been doing a little better
true enough well [ __ ]
looks like i [ __ ] it i didn't [ __ ] it
because i ain't no [ __ ] happening
i had
more soup you got it this time ice cream
and i'm ready
to [ __ ] god
i'm going to
destroy
back to suffer the humiliation of
they never left
bastion up there
i am going to [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
i am out of breath
and it's not a bit
expired
i am full of soup i have a joke in my
head that i'm not gonna say
it would be
untoward and i don't want to be unto
words
[Music]
this is the one everyone at home are you
paying attention
oh [ __ ] that cost me a move did it
[ __ ]
pay attention everyone
this is the moment i've been waiting for
you can't have those you're too stupid
oh [ __ ]
won't work
what about one of uh not that not even
worth it this yes
you fool
you foolish fool
you are a fool
foolish fool
what a fool you are
to challenge me you fool
your world
what why
what huh oh
i see
it
it shan't expire soon at all
it simply shared that grin off your face
i know that costs an extra move but i
felt like it was worth it ah ah this is
why damn it
eat my ass
your time is calm
your time has calm
oh yeah i'm not through you either
hey
[ __ ]
those were mine
i see
i see i see i see
i see right through your moves
i'm 10 000 steps ahead of you
you think you're in control here
no
not today
not today not ever
i got lucky
or did you get foolish all will be chaos
oil will be
cash
that's what you sound like right now
your gifts impress no one my gifts
impress myself and that's all that
matters because my opinion about myself
is the only thing that matters in the
end
all else is secondary
you are not amused
almost too easy look at this
easy
wipe that grin off your face
wipe something else off your face
i want that bell i want the bell but i
can't get the bell
ah maybe i can get the bell
no it's so thoughtful
it's so thoughtful
damn you
oh
come on that was my chance
damn
is that all you've got no
but this is no not yet
but this is
impossible
[Music]
i was destined to beat you
you think you can win just by
eliminating those rows you cannot
because you
you've unlocked my
one strength
that made sense
oh
my strength
[Music]
no
god damn it of course you would but it's
not over yet
you fool
wipe that grin off your face
thoughtful right here
[Music]
don't make me laugh
oh i'm not gonna make you laugh
i'm gonna make you
beg
i've got 33 moves to finish this off
oh let me show you what i've really got
you're not ready
you're not ready at all
you think that shattering a random row
is gonna have any effect on me no
no no no
[Music]
please for the love of god do not get
rid i'm gonna do it anyway i'll exhaust
doesn't matter i cannot risk losing this
my disappointment is immeasurable
mine too baby
mine too
but just you wait
the disappointment has only just begun
oh god no oh wait
oh god
oh no
oh no oh no
please no
not like this
no
okay
just play it safe play it cool
we're just gonna play it cool
just play it cool please
okay well the exhaustion is gonna be
great
it's gonna be perfect actually
finish him off julian you can do just
okay all right you're right there's
nothing i can do to stop you because i
don't want to stop you that's not what
i'm trying to do here okay let me just
get these all synced up here
i need these steps my god i've never
needed stamina more than i do right now
of all things
to get caught up on
right about now
why does it have to be stamina ma
oh it's right there it's right there my
god it's right there
damn it
oh
my god
look at that beauty look at the beaut oh
it's a beaut it's a beautiful
it's a beaut
oh it's mute but oh my god if you delete
okay if you delete
oh thank you thank you you deleted the
correct one oh my god
oh my god okay all right
this is going swimming this means
nothing to me ah sure do sure it do
[Music]
come on you know it dude you know it do
you know it means something
anything yet
oh yeah
how about one of these
impossible
what do you call this boom
boom
aroused yet oh play time is over oh
no wait oh oh okay all right i see i see
ah of course
this can't be happening
my bundys
they're so
he'll never make us orgasm it's
not possible it's not possible
oh oh wait
i guess this is it then oh
all right then hey wait
man these are weird sounds for gods to
make well if only i could make matches
you know but still to this day i i'm
incapable of that
take one of these and this
and some of these
and how about one of these and an
uppercut
and a twisty
and there you go and one of these in a
scootaloo and skip to your lou and blam
at a blim
and thank you ma'am and uh bing bong
bongo blingo blango
blimbo blambo flimbo flambo
sping spang's boody boo
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's really something
oh there's more
oh there's more oh there's more
all right
that's a job well done
that's a job well done right there
that's a job that's a job that's the job
well done you did it
you actually boned the space hooker i
did i sure did
full soup dude man i know i said i
believed in you and all that
but if i'm being completely over some
reason i feel like i gotta sanitize my
hands sure this entire galaxy not lotion
sand sanitizer you really pulled it out
i swear it's hand sanitizer
well technically both
thanks to you the nymphogen are
thoroughly satisfied and have returned
to their cosmic slumber
yep the universe is safe once again
well for another 10 000 years at least
all right well i'll be dead by then so
not my problem
not me though i'll be as tight as ever
okey-dokey then
i can't say i wouldn't miss you though
i hate to admit it but i guess i did
sort of miss your sorry mug over the
past couple years oh
i don't know
being back with you again and
going on another sexy adventure together
yeah it makes me kind of
feel something
not even in my [ __ ] but like
in my chest [ __ ]
i guess
no never mind
oh [ __ ] it i guess what i'm trying to
say is
i love you oh i don't know i hadn't
realized it earlier but
i just can't get you out of my mind i
can't reciprocate those feelings at all
maybe i always loved you and i was just
too proud to admit it that's really nice
but i don't
feel the same clients like this
but i can't deny the way i feel
the truth you're real nice you're not
just a client to me anymore
you're so much more than that
the time we've spent together on this
island has been one of the happiest
times of my life i cherish our
friendship i'm so glad you were chosen
for this
because i wouldn't want to be with
anyone else i would
don't just stand there and leave me
hanging
close your eyes and kiss me you jerk i
won't i refuse i'm not doing this
that's right kiss my big fat ass all
right well i can't see it through all
the blurring oh
man oh you got me
i've pulled that on so many of my
clients
never gets old
good
keep going
[ __ ] the rules rules are for chumps
anyway watching you grind through all
that gash made me hornier than the
nymphogen
besides
somebody has to reward you for saving
the galaxy right oh the least i could do
okay i'll tell you what pick a hole any
hole it's your choice you earned it uh
how about no
if it'll get you to stop talking let's
go for the mouth fine
okay great that's great oh that's
adorable that's just adorable just crop
it out right up here that's lovely
that's lovely it's a good thumbnail
all right
i'll leave you to pack the brim with
beauties
enjoying the alpha mode the dates will
continue to increase in difficulty and
definitely see how many more dates you
can complete
okay cool now salmon the gauntlet and
parking and nebuchadnezzar did with
ronda for underground how many rounds
can you wait before running out of moves
you can now directly purchase even more
hairstyles and office for the girls
using the wardrobe okay wardrobe
wardrobe i have a wardrobe
oh
i'm out of money
i like this stewardess
standard stewardess for me
all right anyway that is hoonie pop 2. i
did it i beat it that was fun i'm really
glad i finally got to get this video to
you after so many months of hard work on
this video alone
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to see more hoonie pop
there's hoonie pop one hunicam studio
and then also get out of here you horny
bastards how the hell are you here after
this entire video
of immense length
okay anyway i'm gonna leave now you
should leave too you go to bed it's
probably extremely late thank you for
watching leave a like if you enjoyed it
let me know what you thought down in the
comments subscribe if you want to see me
finish more games like this
i will probably not play too many horny
ones like this but you never know so
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
bye